Hey everybody,
what the fuck?
It's Valentine's Day almost.
It's coming up soon.
Just one of those dangerous holidays.
We got to do something.
Can't just forget that one.
Valentine's is tricky.
Is it?
Do,
uh,
do the gays give out the flowers
and they give out the flowers?
The flowers traits must give out the flowers,
the gaze as well.
I don't know.
I don't go on dates.
I say no.
The answer is no.
We've got confirmation.
I mean,
either way they end up dying,
you know,
flowers or the gaze.
Both.
Jesus.
We all die.
Flowers and gaze is fucking,
she says,
we're just right off the bat.
I'm trying to sell flowers here,
fellow.
This is a sponsor.
One 800 flowers.com.
A really cool sponsor.
Like going to the florist.
You don't want to get caught in florist.
What happens?
You look like a bitch.
Let's be honest.
If you're a man wandering into a florist,
he looked like somebody done whooped you son,
take care of your shit online.
Keep your hands clean and keep it on the DL.
Uh,
this year,
really?
Wow her with a beautiful bouquet that she would love from one 800 flowers.com.
Your rose authority.
Um,
these are beautiful flowers.
If you look at some of these,
uh,
bouquets that they sell,
for Valentine's Day,
for whatever,
for birthdays,
for anything,
they're really pretty.
Um,
I know it's not manly to love flowers,
but I do flower.
I think they're beautiful.
They're neat.
They're nature's artwork.
I don't know what it is about things that are beautiful that gives you a feeling
like when you see em right here,
Joe,
beautiful forest,
when you see a beautiful sunset,
like I'm not exactly sure what beauty is.
I don't know why it works.
I don't know what it is about looking at flowers and make me go,
wow.
Hmm.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what it is.
I feel the same way when I look at a nice Instagram sunset.
Yeah.
What is that?
But when you see a sunset in real life,
it's better.
Way better,
but really rise.
But what is it about things that are beautiful?
I mean,
I don't know.
Why would it be evolutionary advantageous for us to be attracted to the look of
flowers?
Why would it give us such a good feeling?
It doesn't really make sense.
I don't understand it.
I mean,
did you can't eat?
I guess you can eat them.
You can eat some of them at least,
but that's not it.
I wouldn't say I hate that.
I don't want to eat a flower.
There's supposed to be pretty good.
Yeah,
they're roses salad.
but I mean,
just something,
it's not right.
I have a roses in my yard and deers eat them.
They're always eating my flour.
I should say dear,
but I'm unsophisticated.
Um,
1-800-FLOWERS available through Wednesday,
February 5th only.
That's tomorrow.
You fucks ordered 24 stunning multicolored roses for only 2,999.
That's a really awesome deal.
Like a rose for less than a buck.
24 of them.
Bam.
Multicolored plus for just 10 bucks more.
You can upgrade them to red roses.
I actually think I prefer the multicard.
Yeah.
Diversity.
I know some people just love this.
The classics,
the classics,
the Classic Flower,
the classic red wants to be worth more.
Uh,
it's an amazing offer.
Two dozen roses for 2,999.
This deal ends Wednesday,
February 5th,
and only while supplies last.
So you need to order now before you're locked out son.
You go walking around picking daisies for and she's like,
what bitch daisies?
You Ain't getting none of this.
Right.
Have you ever done that?
Have you ever gone on a date or go over to somebody's house and pick somebody
else's flowers from?
No,
I never have.
I don't.
Um,
I mean I've definitely bought flowers before.
I just can't think of how many times.
It hasn't been a lot,
but I wouldn't,
you know,
I dunno,
man.
People are weird about that.
Like people,
some people want people to buy them shit.
They would rather you buy them shit,
then pick up some flowers somewhere that you saw.
Like,
I would think if I was a check and the guy came over and he said,
I saw these flowers and there were,
you know,
in a field and a wild field and they were really beautiful,
so I thought I'd bring him over.
I would like that even more than someone going to a fucking store where
someone's been raising these things,
they're not special.
Okay.
They're being really on your flowers.
Wild,
wild,
wild flowers looked like shit.
Yeah,
they're kind of want to get some good flowers.
It's got to go to one 800 stamps.com and enter in the code word j r e.
Click on the radio microphone and the upper right hand corner and enter in the
code j r e and get yourself to sweet deal available.
As I said,
Wednesday,
February 5th is when it ends through Wednesday,
February 5th 24 stunning multicolor roses only 2,999 it's been for 10 bucks
more.
You can upgrade them to red roses.
All right,
you fucks.
So go do that chick's ticket.
I don't understand that either,
but look,
you want to get laid right?
You want to keep her happy,
right?
I don't know.
If you want to keep her happy,
you might not want it.
Don't listen to me.
Just don't get that baby's breath stuff.
That's weird.
What is babies brand set that you know what I'm talking about?
It's like that white little,
those little white little things they put in the flowers.
No,
and it has a weird day.
Not like the baby's breath.
Do not get us Bavis breath.
I remember as a kid,
I thought there was a connection from babies.
I know,
I thought it was too.
I was like,
did they steal the breath from babies?
What kind of witchcraft is this?
On Valentine's Day,
we're also brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace who a,
I got a chance to meet the Squarespace guys this weekend in New York City and a
very,
very cool guys.
Uh,
so it's nice to actually put a face to a company.
The company is excellent.
The product,
what they sell,
they have a website where you can make your own website and it's easy.
A dummy like myself could do it.
It's all about drag and drop and point and click.
Just the regular functions of using a computer.
If you're,
you know how to open up Microsoft word,
if you know how to you fuck around
with your iPhone or whatever,
you can figure out how to use Squarespace.
It's not complicated and it is excellent and they let you try it before you even
buy it.
They don't have to enter in your credit card information.
Just sign up,
give it a run,
check it out and you'll go,
oh,
this is pretty fucking bad ass.
And then I'll be like,
I told you bitch.
And then once you do that,
you can get 10% off your purchase for a free trial and 10% off your purchase.
If you enter in the code word Joe,
that's just Joe,
no numbers anymore.
Squarespace wizened the fuck up and dropped the stupid numbers after every show.
One and Joe to
a Squarespace has beautiful designs for you to start with.
You could start not just creating your own website,
but putting on your own online store,
including musicians.
They have it set up really easily,
uh,
where you can really easily sell digital music from your website.
It's a very dope malicious and uh,
we are,
we are very,
uh,
very,
very happy with this company.
That's nice.
Nothing but positive reviews from all of our fans and friends that have,
uh,
have used it,
including a y.
I Know Carrie Santa Maria organized her all over digital media using Squarespace
and Dunkin uses Squarespace.
It was funny because one of the guys was there.
It's like we've got our support ticket for Duncan Trussell and we were like,
wait a minute,
what the fuck is that?
The Real Duncan Trussell and then it was Duncan Duncan Trussell need to figure
out how to do something.
Hey Man,
a 24,
seven email support,
squarespace.com use the code word Joe and save 10%.
Oh,
you fucks were also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com.
That's O.
N.
I t.
Um,
it's 2014 freaks.
Did you blow off your New Year's resolution already?
Is it already over?
Did you already start eating sugar and drinking liquor?
Did you stop working out already?
Go to audits,
outcome o n n I t and get your fucking life in order.
Get a Zombie Bell.
That's kettlebells that look like zombies.
Learn how to use them and prepare for the apocalypse because Yellowstone is
going to blow.
I'm going to talk about that on the podcast today.
Massive volcanic activity.
They need to call Dera Val volcano at Yellowstone so much that they ran out of
red ink.
Oh Shit.
There's so much volcanic activity that the seismograph ran out of ink.
Jesus.
Fucking Louise's.
That's fine.
We're going to go lays down anyway.
Gay Self,
a Zombie Kettlebells,
hair for the apocalypse.
You don't want to be a skinny,
weak bitch when the apocalypse comes and you don't want to smoke cigarettes
either.
So quit the cigarettes and get start off light.
Don't get nutty,
man.
Get yourself like a Goblin.
The brain Goblin one is only 18 pounds.
It seems like it would be too much for a week,
bitch like you.
But I,
I've,
I've confidence that we'll get you a few exercises with 18 pounds and build you
up 35 but most important is,
um,
learn the functional movements of kettle bells before you use any of these
things.
I've said it before,
I'll say it a thousand times cause I don't want anybody getting hurt.
Start off light.
Learn how to do it.
Either go to a trainer and pay someone to show you correct movement or be very
careful and watch a DVD and watch yourself and maybe even film yourself and
watch yourself to see if you're doing the exact same movements as the DVD so you
can really make sure that you're not putting any undue stress on any of your
joints.
Getting injured when you can have,
could have avoided it by being smart is one of the most frustrating things a
person can ever experience because you just feel like such a fucking idiot for
getting injured,
doing something that you could have avoided.
Um,
we sell all sorts of fitness equipment that benefits functional movement.
And what functional movement is.
It's not just bodybuilding exercises that make you look better,
but things that make you your body work as one unit.
Like for the longest time people didn't understand lifting weights.
They would do like one body group this day,
the other body group that day.
And that does make your muscles grow bigger.
But what it doesn't do is get your muscles used to communicating with each other
while doing something and developing your balance and developing your core
strength.
And there's a lot of things at bodybuilding type exercises just don't take care
of.
That's where kettle bells come in.
It's the most effective way to condition your body with weights and you with a
72 pound kettlebell or two 72 pound kettle bells,
you will literally,
I don't care how big you are,
never have to get different kettlebells.
72 pounds.
You can get ruthless workouts with two 72 pound kettle bells,
no matter who you are.
You can be a fucking heavyweight.
You're still gonna get a ruthless workout with two set and they'll last forever.
These fucking things are solid metal.
They will be here long after we're gone.
The aliens will find them and they'll try to fucking piece together are
shattered civilization and they'll try to figure out why we worship zombies and
monkeys,
but the primal bells and the Zombie kettle bells all available at [inaudible]
dot com as well as well as a host of the most nutritious,
most beneficial supplements that we can find all shit that we use ourself,
whether it's hemp forest protein powder,
or organic coconut oil,
or Himalayan salt or super foods like this new supplement that we have that is a
earth grown nutrients,
uh,
all in one daily Greens mix.
Specially beneficial if you just are too busy to get the perfect diet in which
most people are,
uh,
balance yourself out.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o and n I t use a codeword Rogan and save 10% off any
and all supplements.
Boom.
Schelok log.
All right,
my friends mad.
Love.
Good Jo Rogan.
Experience by day.
Joe Rogan,
podcast
dot,
dot dot,
dot.dot.
Captain Martin [inaudible].
What's up guys?
Tape Joe.
How are Ya?
Good.
What's cracking dude?
You know,
live in a dream.
You are living in a dream.
You're living your dream.
Justin Martin live in my dream world.
Yes.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Good things are good until the world ends,
which is tomorrow.
Apparently.
Jesus,
apparently Yellowstone's volcano has been active today.
By the way.
I read one website about this.
Didn't verify it at all.
Um,
not only that,
uh,
I don't want to bear it by it because what if they're wrong and then I can't
freak out for the day.
Yeah,
no reason to freak out.
What time is it?
It's only 12.
20.
Let's wait for a panic attack around like three.
Shelly.
Yeah.
I wonder,
um,
I'll probably have to look at some other websites to see if this is actually
accurate because I've been reading a bunch of things on Fukushima.
It's kind of interesting,
like I was reading like all about radiation and the fish and everything,
but then there's the scientist that I was reading,
like they coulda caught a halibut from right off shore from Fukushima and we've
tested it and it was okay to eat liars,
right?
Yeah.
My Dad owned me.
Like I was like,
I wish I could go back to Japan.
And he was like,
why wouldn't you go back to Japan?
And I'm like,
well,
you know,
the radiation.
He goes,
you know,
there's people that work at round that radiation plan they had,
they could only work there like five days in a row,
but they have to get out of there before it starts affecting them.
But it's not like you're going to go over there and
no shitting Brian.
They're mutants now.
They have powers.
Yeah.
You don't know shit.
Yeah,
you're wrong.
Here's a,
here's a thing about the Yellowstone thing.
No,
no.
Is this today?
This is today.
Yeah.
I'm reading about y'all stone volcanic activity.
So what are they saying?
Uh,
hear me.
There's actually,
okay.
Is this the,
um,
the newest?
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Huge magma pocket lurks beneath Yellowstone.
Super Volcano,
not a magma pocket.
A large earthquake at Yellowstone is much more likely than a volcanic eruption.
They said,
God dammit,
just let me shoot a pilot.
You know,
that's all I wanted.
It's so close.
It's supposed to be this month.
Let me hit syndications.
Let me get something.
Jesus.
Okay.
Yeah.
seismic stations send information could continuous.
What's up with that sound up park to their lab at the University of Utah within
Yellowstone is a Caldera or volcano whole 50 miles across so big.
You can't see it from the ground.
A little below the surface as a pool of molten rock called magma cause shoulder.
In this 60 minutes graphic,
he from the magma drives yellow stones.
Geysers such as old faithful researchers use the seismic waves from earthquakes
like the x rays to see the magma underground.
By the way,
hold on.
Sorry.
It's two and a half times larger than that guy fucking freaks me out.
Just by the way,
Tom,
talking about mad my dad was,
he mentioned if the guy was over your house and be like,
oh my God,
I have a crazy person on my house.
Look how they're talking to me for dad or this is where the volcanoes going to
kill us all.
She,
you wanted to make the volcano under Yellowstone.
He's much more animated.
He's like the worst like fourth grade teacher ever.
The science teacher to potential is 2000 times the force of Mount Saint Helens.
This is a new study from the University of Utah.
The Hot Molten Brock between Yellowstone beneath Yellowstone is two and a half
times larger than previously estimated.
Oh my God.
I watched a doom and gloom documentary on Yellowstone that freaked me out about
seven years ago and now they've got new findings and it's twice as bad as they
thought it was.
Oh,
what is this
styles and years ago?
No one knows if or when it will erupt again,
but if it does,
it'll be big.
Ash comes all the way to salt lake or Denver researchers think Dell see the
eruption coming and we believe we'd have a bit of warning if there was going to
be a volcanic eruption at Yellowstone.
Three seconds.
All of I'm,
yeah,
I'm going somewhere.
I don't know where I'm going,
but I'm going somewhere.
I think Australia,
that's a good one.
That's a beautiful prison colony.
They're nice people.
They like to party.
They're smart.
[inaudible] smart country.
If this happens,
is it going to trigger the big one here?
That's something to think about it.
That doesn't matter,
man.
Do you understand how big this is?
But this fucker blows.
It's like from what that guy said,
he said to be like 50 miles across,
but I've read that it's much larger than that I need for volcano.
Yeah.
I read that it was like the,
the entire base of the crater was something nutty like 300 kilometers,
like something insane that apparently if this thing blows,
it kills most of the animals on the continent and it's not just going to be like
an issue for people that live around Yellowstone.
It's going to be an issue for people that live in Portugal.
It's going to be be an issue for China.
It's going to be an issue for the whole planet.
It'll cause like a giant cloud that will cover the sky and probably kill off
like a lot of people and animals.
It's probably going to kill most people that kill off gluten won't kill off
sugar gluten or Kale,
Italy.
Yeah.
You can't buy any more organic.
Oh God.
There'll be no organic.
Everything will be done in these things underground with light bulbs.
Everything will be nuclear power.
Yeah.
Fake light on nuclear power where I'll be living underground cave pirates.
Well this is a bunch of fucking be but we Dunkin interviewed this guy for the
Scifi show where he went and talked to,
this dude has got this organized retreat underground and doomsday layer.
Think it was Utah.
Yeah.
I forget where it was but homeboy had like you drove into it.
It was like a bomb shelter.
He drove into it with buses and you know these tunnels and then they had like
oxygen machines and they were setting like a whole colony in there where they
were going to grow food.
This is where they're going to store their supplies.
This is where they were going to have their like recreation room and they're
going to have a daycare there.
Like this one dude was I I think basically thinking about like getting together
a group of women and fucking them all and killing off the husbands.
I think that's not a cult leader.
I'm just a guy with a bomb shelter.
Come on.
Who doesn't have a good bomb shelter these days?
That's the best way,
ladies,
come on in.
If you were right though,
like the dudes who want to be a cult leaders be so psyched for the apocalypse.
I can walk.
Yeah.
Now I'm running shit.
No more law.
There's no more rules.
The Internet's down.
Fuck yeah,
I can trick these Dominican where this eyepatch and look hardcore.
It was hard.
It's hard as fuck to trick people in 2014 you know,
if you,
you go,
you know,
making some shit up and starting some new religion and then they go,
well let me Google searches guy and you go him.
He's a fucking con man.
You know that.
That's not going to go far.
But like,
you know,
Joseph Smith was a con man.
Joseph Smith was a con man and he started Mormonism.
If,
if that,
if you tried to do that today,
people would be like,
dude,
I googled you last night.
Yeah.
Fuck off.
That's the best response to anything googled you to fuck off.
I know what you tell you.
You're all bullshit,
man.
You can find a golden tablets,
the branch Davidians and the,
yeah,
those guys.
Well,
the Waco one,
it's really spooky because the government killed those people.
And you know,
I mean,
I've been there.
I,
yeah,
I don't know if it's a,
I mean,
I don't know if they attacked first.
I don't know what the exact situation was,
but I know they lied about what they did because they wrote over those buildings
with tanks and shot fire until those buildings like tear gas and stuff.
Yeah.
You could see the videos of it.
There's a,
there's a,
I think it's called rules of engagement.
Is that what it is?
That's about me.
Make sure that that's what it is.
I think that's the documentary of engagement.
Okay.
But it's all about Waco.
It's about what the,
yeah,
that's,
yeah.
Okay.
Um,
but those,
I mean,
they were definitely fucking crazy people.
Waco,
the rules of engagement.
That's the name of the documentary you can find it on now.
It's on Youtube,
the full version of it.
It's on youtube.
So just Google Waco.
WAAC.
Oh.
And if you're interested in watching it,
it's pretty fucking interesting,
man.
Um,
they put think it's creepy.
I've been there.
They killed the fuck out of those people.
You know,
they've got guns and they have,
uh,
the,
the foundation of the building and it says,
uh,
the most televised massacre in the world.
And it shows it's spray paints,
like arrows in each direction on the tablet,
on the foundation where it's like,
oh,
CNN was here and you know,
Fox News was here.
Like how it was all televised for everyone to see.
Yeah.
That is what happened.
They massacred those people and they did it right in front of everybody.
It's really interesting.
I mean,
it was a 51 day siege,
and at the end of the 51 days they were like,
he fucking nef.
Yeah.
What's,
it's fascinating because I can't side with that dude.
You know,
I can't side with Koresh.
he's obviously,
it was a cult leader.
He's obviously one of those charismatic Weirdos.
Yeah.
What's fucking all the women he was having sex with all the women and the kids
too.
Some of the kids.
Oh,
I don't know if that's true.
Kids having kids.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
So I'm not,
I'm not saying that he was a great guy and he's just still be around.
Running is called,
but the way to handle it might not be smashing buildings,
tanks for the approver with a tanker in canning and cooking kids.
I mean,
they cooked everybody.
Yeah,
they knocked him victim,
but they killed everybody that was in that.
They had tunnels down there too.
They had tunnels underground and all that.
So they smoked them all out and yeah.
How many people died at Waco?
Wake up happy Tuesday.
I say,
Oh,
Dad,
I'm going to say a hundred and say more.
Yeah.
Siri.
How many people died in Waco?
I'm sorry,
who?
What?
Stop creeping me out.
Joe Broken 76 Oh,
76 yeah,
that's a lot of,
I thought more.
Yeah.
Do you imagine 76 bodies stacked up on top of each other?
No,
not really,
man.
That is crazy.
The ATF failed to raid the compound,
so the FBI jumped in,
so apparently they'd been shooting back and forth at each other.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Oh God,
I remember seeing that in the,
in the windows and stuff.
She can't shoot at the cops dummy.
Yeah.
In my culture can mean that's,
that's uh,
there's a certain amount of bullshit they're not going to tolerate.
You can't shoot a cop.
That's what did we go wrong?
That's where they,
it's really fucking roll over your buildings tanks.
That's when they did that.
It's interesting because,
uh,
I had seen like Bill Hicks,
she used to have a bid on it.
You know,
about,
uh,
the,
the United States.
We're liars and murderers because you could watch the video of them rolling
tanks through these buildings.
Billowing fire out of the end of the tanks.
And it wasn't like a funny bit,
it was more like,
you know,
he had some bits that were really just sort of a,
who's showing you like,
like,
this is what you're dealing with.
These are the kinds of thugs you're dealing with.
Yeah.
They,
they blew fire.
But then you look at the other side and you know,
well,
they're shooting at cops.
Yeah.
They're fucking kids.
Uh,
the guy plays a really shitty guitar.
Yeah.
He just liked to party.
She knows.
Yeah,
he's banging everybody's wife and he's got guns and he shoots at cops and
they're like,
oh right.
Yeah.
Okay.
Run him over.
All right.
What about the kids?
Kids are gonna grow up to be assholes.
Yeah.
Good point.
Little inbred misfit fraggled.
Have you ever seen him sing?
Pull up David Koresh,
David Koresh singing David Koresh.
David Koresh sings the blues and all new time-life classic.
Let's see if you can see yourself the worst moments of your life.
Could you see yourself falling for any of this bullshit now,
that's what I call,
I just want him to have like an album release party.
Put aside what you know or think you know about David Koresh.
Listen to his words recorded just before his death.
No,
and the death of his entire family.
Oh,
they have a video of him.
How many of us have said the same thing?
Pull this up.
David Koresh tells the Truth About Waco.
This is a video of them.
Right before the,
the Fed stormed the building and cooked everybody.
What was the most entertaining thing Waco has ever seen it?
I'm sure.
Well,
um,
you know,
a lot of people went down there when the standoff was going on and they were
like hanging out with the cops,
like watching.
It was a spectacle,
which is fucking really odd,
especially when you find out how it turned out.
Yeah.
Like that's what you're actually watching.
You got it again.
David Koresh.
David Koresh tells the Truth About Waco.
Okay.
It's a him inside the branch.
Davidian I mean it's,
it's really creepy because he,
I think he'd already been shot by the time they did this.
Listen to his words,
according just before his death and the death of his entire family.
She's just so dramatic.
How many of us have said the same thing?
No.
I guess to buy a firearm,
it's not against the law because to buy anything to say selling a gun show
and one,
this is all resolved,
you know,
hey,
yellow seed is illegal.
Accusation is not,
I can't listen to it around here.
I'll tell you what,
being an American first,
I'm the kind of guy and I,
I'll stand in front of a tank.
You can run over me,
then I'll be back more than the track.
No one's going to hurt me or my family.
The American policy here,
he's awesome.
There's road.
You could have arrested me going to town or going to Walmart.
Walmart.
Michael is going to bear witness against the ATS and the two ages across the
street over here.
Uh,
Robert Gonzalez.
I love the guy.
I was honest with him.
I brought him into my home.
He was going to stay there for two weeks.
All of this stuff you may eat,
guys may want to avoid and deny,
you know,
he wanted a tour around the place.
I promised him a tour.
He could have talked to any of these guys around here.
Anybody.
He was free to come and go as he chose.
And I do not appreciate it and never will I ever appreciate somebody coming here
with two helicopters in cow cow and trailers and all that and uh,
pushing people around with guns.
He,
I'll meet you at the doorstep any day and you know,
and somebody will get hurt if you want to keep playing that game.
I'm talking to you,
nobody's going to get hurt because let's say in America anymore with ATF has
that kind of power become into anybody's home and Keith doors down and things
like that.
I heard,
I do understand that someone reminded me of this.
I do understand that one of the officer says gun went off on accident and then
you know,
that was just like a signal and all that,
but look beside the point ATS,
he pours the wrong
practices.
Your habits.
Yeah,
drug dealers,
fine.
You know,
but even there's always a question.
If there's any question whatsoever that kids are women or as Bob Damn you,
I tell you why you keep your damn gun and your whole shirt.
You see the couple of big brave is burstable kind of and you must him knock on
the door,
30 food,
Bam.
Involved to where they can risk their lives for the name of the wall and send
them my bulletproof.
Put them in some kind of Vibe,
knight armor or ever.
I let him knock on the door and ask the questions.
First
One's going to expect me when they come busted on my door with guns drawn and
pointing in the air.
It's the one part of me that I'm going to lay down and die for anybody.
This is then going to happen in this country.
No,
it's fucked.
It's like part of what he's saying,
like you shouldn't come in to people's houses with if you have any questions,
guns drawn.
If there's women and children.
He's like,
that makes a good point.
Yeah.
Like why not wear like a bulletproof outfit?
Wouldn't that be like a more,
you know,
have a bunch of people with bulletproof Halfords don't storm into the house with
fucking guns with kids and look,
he's obviously a redneck.
He's Kenny powers.
Yeah,
he looks,
yeah,
he definitely loves Walmart.
He's Kenny powers.
He gets the candy powers evangelists is,
he gets a,
here's the question,
man.
Okay.
What if a guy,
let's say there's some guy,
some slick talking guy and he finds some sad girls and the two girls live with
them.
Any,
any has this like Harem of these two girls.
There's two girlfriends.
It takes them everywhere and then make a show of it.
Shoe Hugh Hefner style.
Yeah.
Like he's kissing them all out in public.
All right.
That's okay.
But I just,
I think you pitched a show for Bravo right now.
I think that's actually really cause a new show.
This guy moves in with two girls.
They're lost.
They're lost and sad.
They can't afford food.
Yeah.
So this Guy Mike,
a racist,
their memories.
But you know what I'm saying?
What I'm saying is like when does it become a cult?
Okay.
If,
if you're got,
if you've got two gals,
that's okay.
Everybody's like,
well,
it's just an eccentric lifestyle.
Okay,
but what does she amorous right.
That's what I call a polyamorous.
But if you have 30 of them,
yeah.
And it's you and your five friends and you all swap wives and you live in a
place and your gun enthusiasts,
then you're,
then you're getting into the learning channel right now.
That's,
that's exactly what that is.
That's all.
I mean,
I'm patient,
I'm thinking shows and I'm like,
oh,
those dollar signs,
Joe,
we've got two days to live before the magma piles up on our bodies.
Money's not worth anything anymore.
You need bitcoins.
I don't know.
That is an interesting thing where it's like that.
It's like the um,
God,
where is that?
I was,
we were driving by that place.
It's like,
I,
um,
it is like a Mormon or,
or one of those big love plots where everything's boarded up.
They have no outlet to society.
Like I just,
when do you,
when do you go?
Hmm,
this sounds like a great idea.
As long as it's old,
it's okay.
It can be very cold.
Like it could be like the Amish where they're like bakers.
They were,
Quakers are fine as long as it's old.
But if it's like creepy,
well,
no,
the Amish are creepy.
Well,
you know,
you've used electricity.
That's creepy.
Make their own butter.
That's so cute.
That is kind of cute.
It's kind of cute.
But their outfits are ridiculous.
That's really done massive restriction on their activities.
Um,
but there've been around a long time so it's okay.
But if like Justin Martin Dale decided to start the,
the Martindale's and this is your new a religion.
The religion of the Martindale aliens.
Yeah.
Dress up like they're a band member and Divo you know,
if I can have like a bunch of specific shit you make them all do.
Then everyone lives in this gated community that fucking feds would come and
knock on your door.
Where are you getting the ECC?
What ECC we talking to talking about it.
I'm just grinding my teeth.
I love it.
I'm hydrating though.
Hey,
I pay taxes,
get the fuck off me.
Next thing you know,
you'd be getting arrested,
be having too much fun.
But if it was just you living with a couple of dudes,
partying it up all the time,
no one would say shit.
If three guys share a house and they just have parties all the time and they
like to go dancing and they like to eat and go drink and bring people home and
have more parties,
nobody gives a fuck.
Yeah,
that's just called Palm Springs.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That's a house.
It's fine.
It's nothing wrong with it.
As long as your neighbors don't freak the fuck out.
But once the neighbors freak out.
But if you have 50 guys and they all lived in like these five houses that you
had fenced in,
sure.
That will be a real issue.
You know,
there's 10 guys in each house and they're all,
they grow their own food.
Oh.
Oh,
that's weird.
Oh these fucks.
They have solar backups.
They have generators there.
They seem to be digging a well,
oh we've got to fucking stop this.
Say Anti American.
And they try and do is try and get off the grid.
Huh?
Were you doing anything?
Hey Fox tried to be self sustaining growing their own weed.
Oh No.
Probably that's what everybody looks for.
That's what everyone's doing these days.
There's a great story about these uh,
CIA agents that got,
uh,
arrested because of the DEA thought that they were growing weed and they were
actually growing tomatoes.
That's funny.
They'd go by their house with those scanners.
Oh,
to pick up the,
to pick up the scent or something?
No,
the scanner,
they have those in Denver now,
but apparently they're being ruled unconstitutional or there's some sort of a
dispute about them now.
These are some things that they use outside to find out how much electricity
that the house is using.
Oh,
I see.
If like you,
you have like a series of glow lights or grow grow lights,
rather,
it'll give off a very specific signal outside the house.
Like they can find out if you're growing things.
So they knew these guys were growing thanks to,
they came in broken in their house and found that they have fucking tomato.
They're using those lights for the tomato plants.
Yeah.
It was just so bored now.
Who's growing weed?
Yeah,
I'll,
I'll pull up the story because it's so fucking stupid.
It hurts your brain.
That would be amazing to be those people.
They're like their tomatoes.
Yeah,
they have fucking,
what are you doing it,
it happens all the time,
by the way.
Um,
there's,
there's a bunch of stories online.
Um,
you can,
you can find them all over the place where people were busted from growing
tomatoes.
Um,
my sister,
my,
my brother in law was growing tomatoes in the basement.
I mean,
people do it all the time.
Especially in the east coast.
You have a piece of your basement,
you set up some lights,
you can have food.
Now why wouldn't you do it?
But this is a funny fucking story because it's two former CIA employees and
they're in Kansas and their home was broken down and searched for a in a two
state drug sweep claim.
They were illegally.
That's hilarious.
So they were Xca and homeless?
No.
What are you talking about?
The homeless.
Oh,
no,
no.
There was,
their home was invaded.
I was like,
these,
these are just homeless people invading someone's house.
That's awesome.
This is how stupid this idea of the drug war is.
And this war on plants,
their operation,
the operation was operation constant gardener.
Yeah.
The aborigine of Gardner.
If people are growing plants,
is it okay to grow things?
No.
It's not.
Stop creating life.
No,
it's not.
We decided it's not operation,
home and garden.
So we will,
we will most think about all the different things you can grow that aren't
illegal.
Okay.
And then if you're growing something,
we assume it's illegal and we have the right to break down your fucking door.
We've lost a lot of rights folks.
We've lost a lot of rights.
That's,
that's really weird.
It's really weird.
I mean these dummies are doing this to ex CIA agents.
God,
we found plants.
Tomatoes.
Yeah.
It's fucking stupid,
man.
It's a stupid,
stupid,
stupid situation.
Yeah.
Fucking dumb asses.
That's why he used to grow my weed underneath my waterbed like the Florida.
Of course you did.
It doesn't matter.
It's still fine.
Like we had enough room.
You'd have the shittiest we'd ever,
it's much farts to
waterbeds and farts.
I always liked the way waterbed smell though.
They're weird to sleeping man.
Cause they like a womb.
I had to go when I lived in Boston.
Is there bad for fucking though?
The only way you get a good fuck on a waterbed is you've got to get in a corner.
That makes sense for race,
your legs,
one leg on each side and you gotta you gotta figure out how to ride going
sloshing.
Yeah.
Just cause it's gotta be sloshing.
Even if you have those waterbeds and have baffles in them.
Like a lot of them have baffles in them so they only wiggle a little.
It's not quite the same.
Once you get a good fuck on and like a real solid bed,
a bed like a tempurpedic one,
it's got a good fucking give to it.
Cause their tempurpedic.
Waterbeds no it was tempurpedic bed.
Regular beds.
You don't even pay attention to anything you think is hot pilots.
No,
I don't think about putting together shows.
That would be amazing.
That'd be the best bet ever.
Cause I'm thinking waterbeds are the most uncomfortable bad's ever.
They are awesome.
I had a bad water bad.
That was just me then.
Well uncomfortable to you.
How about that?
Yeah.
Was it one of those ones that you sink right to the middle?
Those are the problems.
That's what we were talking about,
like baffles,
you know,
baffles meaning there's a bunch of different compartments.
It's still a waterbed,
but there's many different compartments.
Not just one big one that the wiggles around.
There's like,
you know,
hundreds of them.
So you sit in it and you would just wiggle.
Just sort of a,
just a tiny little wiggle just tiny little bit.
But um,
the heat off of the waterbed,
it's what's fascinating because it gives you this weird like deep sleep feeling
like you're being like you're in a wool Lincoln.
Yeah,
in Utero,
but I fucked up once and my heater stopped or something.
I don't remember it a long time ago.
But you get so fucking hole if you're sleeping over a waterbed and the heater
breaks you like you could get like hypothermia,
tannic shit.
Yeah.
It fucking,
you freeze your Dick off.
Like I'm sitting there going,
I can't believe how fucking cold this.
It's like,
I thought it'd be fine.
I didn't realize that.
No,
the water is going to like suck the heat out of your body.
It's not like it's not warm anymore.
You just wake up blue.
If you wake up,
it's not like a mattress,
like a mattress is the temperature of the room and that's fine,
but you can't have a waterbed,
the temperature of the room,
the waterbed,
it's 70 degrees.
You're fuck yeah,
I want a warm bed and he don't warrant that
popped.
My cat ended up popping mine and I woke up and into the water I was with a girl
on the water.
Just started coming up.
That's a weird way to wake up.
You're like,
are you picking on me and cats?
Silly cat.
I popped a water bed wants,
that's a disaster,
man.
It's a disaster.
And you got to fucking do something quick because the apartment is going to fill
up with water and it's going to go through the floor.
And if you're above somebody there,
you know they're full of shit.
Ah,
where are you?
Where are you above some ways.
Uh,
I was,
I mean,
I was above someone,
but it didn't get that bad.
I took care of it before it went crazy.
That's scary.
I don't even remember how,
I don't remember what the process of draining it was and it's like a Tan,
attach a hose and get the hose and carry it to the Sangamon,
siphon it and then pour it in or something.
I don't even remember the full,
full,
full boat of issues,
but I remember when I got a regular bad after that,
I was like,
fuck waterbeds man,
this is what a bed's supposed to be like silly goddamn gimmick bed.
Do they still make water bed sores?
They do fight anybody.
I'm going to Google dope waterbed.
It's just got a waterbeds and stuff.
They have those ones with a like fishing them now and shit.
Yeah.
That's ridiculous.
Bunch of fucking fish shitting over your head.
Um,
dope.
Waterbeds waterbeds.com it doesn't have much waterbeds and stuff.
Has it.
Alternative to water beds.
Hmm.
Waterbed suggestions.
Waterbeds still making ways in Google news.
Oh,
that was clever.
How they said that.
My bed still making waves on my recent trip to Florida.
Of course,
flora picked up the Sarasota Herald Tribune one day and started to flip through
it.
[inaudible] I stopped at,
uh,
shut the fuck up.
Boring the piss out of shitty writer
fucking dummy.
What if it was the guy who was,
he was narrating the magma thing.
He was like,
Oh,
I bought this water bad.
There's a guy named waterbed who's on Twitter or a tumbler.
Okay.
Oh,
it's waterbeds on Tumbler.
Yeah.
So they still make them and they have that what you were talking about Justin,
what it looks like with a foam on top,
the tempurpedic.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
But see how it has all those layers to it.
That's how they do it.
Just like the Earth's crust.
Oh No.
Back to yellow stone going to die.
Waterbeds and magma to what if this shit is like awesome.
Now we should try it.
I would like to try it right now.
I want to try a tempurpedic waterbed.
It's like sleeping in like a little like hot pocket.
Like a little sandwich.
That's probably would be pretty good.
Yeah,
it's the warmth of the water bed.
That's really awesome.
Yeah.
Especially when you live in a cold place.
Which,
uh,
I was in Chicago one weekend and then New York last weekend.
Cool.
Goddamn you appreciate La when you get back from that.
Yeah.
You're like,
isn't it an amazing what we don't have to deal with?
Yeah.
You don't have to like,
yeah,
freeze or eat your grandma's.
But you know,
but here's the voters.
Like those fucking poor people in that house.
His Dad alive,
that movie where they were trapped in the mountains and they ate it.
They ate it with a spoon alive.
It was the soccer team wasn't it?
Does ass cheeks atlas spoiler and ate it.
Hey,
times are tough.
You got to eat that.
That's got to do what you gotta do.
That's it.
Good.
Maybe.
Do you know the thing about those warm climates though,
as opposed to cold climates?
Cold climates develop cooler people,
goddammit.
I hate saying it,
but it's fucking true.
Hmm.
There's something about those cold climates that like,
people,
they develop more character.
Yeah.
Well,
it kind of makes them human and like they're all in it together and they all
know it sucks.
Yeah.
So they're like,
why are we going to,
yeah,
it's like here.
I think it's warm.
It's always nice.
So I think people just numb to it.
Everyone's just a dick.
Everyone is just an asshole.
I just think we live in a very medicaid city too.
I don't know.
I don't know what the actual numbers.
I smell weed everywhere.
I got that way,
man.
That's the good medicated.
I'm such a hypocrite.
I'm like,
people are just doing drugs all the time.
Everywhere.
They're just doing all these paraphernalias.
They're all just escaping rehab.
Everyone Punch a week pitch each and every one of them.
You're talking pills.
Fucking people a week,
dude.
Everyone's just trying to escape
the,
uh,
this,
um,
this is a Xanax and a antidepressants.
It,
okay,
game on.
Let's go.
It's a Xanax in antidepressant culture.
We need a little snap.
Little snow to shovel wouldn't hurt anything.
There's one of those.
It's one of those things where I hear that every day.
I hear Xanax or I hear Valium or I here.
What's the,
um,
what's the upper one?
Maggie's,
Huh?
Matthiessen overall,
all that one.
I like a really good game of crazy or on meth.
I think that's a good street game.
I play with myself.
Like you just see people now we're just like,
and you're just like,
what is going on?
And then you're like,
oh,
they're on math.
I'm seeing a lot of women on meth now.
Really?
Like,
yeah,
like young girls and especially on sunset.
Whoa.
Starts Math in 2014 amateurs.
People that can afford
or is it people like,
man,
I don't believe the hype.
I don't know.
I mean there was a story on it.
Uh,
there's a guy in Hollywood who does a thing like it's a like Hollywood night
angel program or something because a lot of kids on in Hollywood who move out
here and you know,
they don't,
they're homeless and their dreams aren't working out,
whatever.
They just start doing it and like this guy goes around and helps them,
gives them shoes,
all that kind of stuff.
And he's like,
it's a,
it's a huge epidemic in Hollywood.
And I think,
I'm pretty sure everywhere else,
but I could never,
I could never do that.
You can never do that or heroin or any of that
stuff.
It's a huge epidemic all over the country.
Maths,
maths is a big one.
[inaudible] so weird one too because um,
it's Kinda like universally accepted as being bad,
but yet it's everywhere.
Yeah.
It's a w he had a show about it,
you know,
it's like kind of glorifying it in a weird way almost.
Right.
It was a little bit like,
it was a great,
great,
don't,
don't say it
like,
yeah,
but I mean,
in order to make an effective piece of fiction,
yeah.
And I got to make it a little crazy and exciting,
but the weird thing about methods,
it's so God damn popular that they decided to make like fake versions of math
and calm bath salts and sell that.
I mean,
is that still a thing fuck yet?
Till that salts are,
yes.
Huh.
You know why?
Because there's so many different ways they could sell things.
They can change so many different aspects of whatever the illegal drug is.
Like Adam oxygen molecule,
that phosphorus or whatever,
the cocktail kind of.
Yeah.
They can add things and twist things like say if you have a very specific drug,
like you have a new thing that you created called dunk,
you know all man who's are doing donk,
Matt Dong,
it fucks you up and dunk is hashtag whatever the chemical composition for is.
If they just add and then the government makes donkey illegal.
If he does add an oxygen molecule dunk,
even though it still fucks you up beyond repair,
it's not donkey anymore because now it's got this other thing.
So chemically speaking it's a different thing.
It's Dank,
so becomes legal and then he say not for human consumption and you sell it like
bath salts.
So that's essentially essentially what they did.
But doc,
but bath salts aren't over the counter though,
right?
You have to.
Yes,
they are over.
They used to sell them a gas stations used to be able to buy them at seven 11 no
I don't.
I shouldn't say seven 11 I should say convenience stores.
I don't have,
I don't think,
actually a matter of fact,
I'm pretty sure seven 11 never carry any of the stores like head shops that
synthesized
stuff.
No,
no.
What you're thinking of is,
I dunno if you think of the synthesizer,
you thinking about weed,
it's fake weed.
No,
no,
no.
Fake weed is just fake weed.
It's just glad there's some fake we that has like some psychoactive effect
apparently,
but it doesn't feel like weed and it's really shitty.
Like,
or the that's wait is horrible.
It's terrible.
A lot of hospitals from people taking it off cause you can like,
it messes with your head.
I,
I've taken some fake weed before.
Meanwhile,
by the way,
there's a fucking store that's on yeah,
the Internet about a woman in the UK that died from cannabis poisoning,
but,
huh.
Uh Oh shit.
The idea that she's the first person to ever die from we'd ever,
and the the,
I don't know what fucking newspaper,
it's like the Daily Mail here.
I'll pull it up.
Woman dies from wheat.
Yeah.
It's supposedly she w she overdosed but she's not possible.
She overdosed on.
Where is she in Canada.
How old was she?
She was younger.
She was cute and uh,
yeah,
she didn't mind much,
much inner system though or something
through.
She had a heart attack.
Yeah.
She just had,
she had a moderate doses of marijuana in her system and she had a heart attack.
It's not that we'd killed her.
Who knows what killed her.
She could have had some sort of an issue with her heart,
you know,
who knows what it was.
But marijuana and takes the els when they,
when they tested drug,
like say if it's a acid or LSD or mushrooms or Mtma,
they have a thing called the LD 50 and the LD 50 is lethal dose for 50% of the
population.
So safe.
If we,
they gave all of us in this room,
you know,
a thousand milligrams,
whatever the fuck it is.
If it kills two of us,
that's LD 50.
That's the dosage that like 50% of people are going to fucking die.
This is a pretty bad stuff because it doesn't kill everybody.
Like you'd probably give Joey Diaz
enough to kill all of us to come by and he would survive.
It doesn't work in every weeks out of the ashes.
But if you gave like little Esther half of what we kill us.
So we killed her.
Yeah.
So lethal dose at 50% of the population were from marijuana.
It's 1500 pounds.
Stop and think about that.
That's a lot.
Okay,
let's,
let's make sure that I'm correct about that.
LD 50 of marijuana.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
So do you think it's this one shit coroner or whatever,
just uh,
being a retard or do you think they're trying to like push something,
you know that before just trying to make this story now,
why am I picturing this girl like naked in the snow?
Like is that,
I don't know,
like what she does she smoke and like wander out into the field and die.
Or like we're shooting our apartment were,
were,
was she?
Listen to this,
a smoker.
Okay.
Let's the,
in order to a marijuana smoker would have to consume 20,000 to 40,000 times as
much marijuana as is contained in one marijuana cigarette
bullshit.
Canada
regular marijuana cigarette has approximately 0.9 grams.
Smoker would theoretically have to consume nearly 1500 pounds of marijuana
within 15 minutes to produce a lethal response.
It's one o'clock now.
Should we start?
I can't.
I have shit to do today.
I'm busy.
That's an all day experience of God.
One thing you can't do is smoke 1500 pounds of marijuana and then get shit done.
Yeah,
right.
You'd just be on Facebook.
What's all live?
One pound of marijuana is that you could smoke 1300 pounds of marijuana in 15
minutes.
It'd be fine.
That's what everyone's missing here.
Like if the LD 50 is 1500 pounds,
we can probably each one of us smoke a thousand pounds safely.
We would shut down every Carl's Jr God,
you'd shut down every cell in your body.
You would probably transcend space and time and become a God.
You,
you probably what it would be David Koresh.
You would probably have a whole new perspective on all these guys.
I'm traveling.
They were just a little off.
They were a little off the fucking,
the guys who cut their dicks off down in the San Diego.
Oh,
sneakers on.
Remember those days,
the Koolaid guns off?
Just don't,
no,
no.
Those were the Africans are,
those are the South American guys.
That was where it was.
David Koresh.
No,
I'm Jim Jones was in Guyana tragedy.
Yeah,
sure.
Jonestown.
Yeah.
I think that was Guyana,
which is a South America,
right,
Diana,
hasn't it?
Uh,
either way.
1500 pounds.
So shut the fuck up.
That's ridiculous.
All of those people that said that it was a woman died of Canada's poisoning.
She did not.
She data food
and you know,
that had to hit every single local news station and saw your mom.
Did you want to be number two?
You want to be the second child to die and leave.
Your mother,
child was raised you.
You call it to me for another dimension.
I brought you into this existence and I didn't do it.
So you can be a fucking pot had called me from another dementia coming with Mama
to church.
Come on,
let's pray.
Let's pray.
My Lips are vibrating.
War Cry,
mixed my lips itch.
There's so many dumb fucks in this world.
Whoever put that story out,
every one of them should be sued.
You should be sued for fraud.
He should be sued for misrepresenting the facts.
You should be sued.
I should.
You shouldn't really be sued.
So just yell at you though.
And I don't want anybody sued.
I don't want anybody being dragged to the legal system.
Even for something that's stupid.
But it is.
Dom is fuck.
There are dumb people who remember that fire like a week ago.
The big,
the one over.
And um,
yes.
Where was there a Glendora.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So this is my favorite Tom Story for the past week was that was outside.
I was like,
oh look at the sky,
because it was turning the sky pink.
It was kind of really nice.
And this girl was like,
what's going on with the thigh?
And I was like,
oh,
there's a fire in Glendora.
She's like,
Oh,
oh.
I thought it was like another sunrise.
And I was like,
what?
I've just looked at her.
I was like,
what?
She's like,
yeah,
I thought the sun was rising again.
I'm like,
yeah,
cause we live on Pandora.
Dumb,
dumb bitch.
God,
I was,
I've never wanted to just rip out a throat and just say fatality more in my
life.
There's a problem with the world is that,
uh,
you making fun of this one girl,
someone could say Justin Martin.
Dale,
you hate women.
I don't hate women.
Women.
I adore women.
I am America's gay best friend.
He's not a tricky thing though.
Isn't that tricky?
The tricky thing,
like if you bash any woman,
oh,
I haven't told on stage that.
They're like,
oh,
you just have woman issues.
I'm like,
no,
I don't.
I love women.
I'm bitch issues.
Anybody can be a dumb bitch though.
Fuck yeah,
I dump cons and there you go.
If you make fun of men,
nobody ever accused you hating men.
And then a weird thing,
I don't want to make you fucking guys ever and no one assumes you're talking
about the entire gender.
Yeah.
But if you'd talk about,
think everybody just knows that guys are stupid,
guys are stupid.
Women are stupid.
Everyone is stupid.
Can we all just be on board?
It'd be stupid.
Yeah,
there's most of us were stupid.
A good chunk of the time.
Yeah.
I mean there's plenty of evidence of me being stupid just online.
You could find it.
It's there.
I don't know.
Maybe it's just like an la thing.
Like I find myself around town and just I,
I,
I listened to other what,
what people are talking about.
Like,
like something we'll,
someone will say something and I'll just,
and I'm very vocal about it.
I was just looking,
just be like,
ah,
what's wrong with you?
God,
that's the stereotypical bitchy gay guy.
No,
but it's not bitchy.
I'm not like,
I'm an intelligent eminent that's wrong with you.
That is,
if she defied sound like [inaudible] my friend [inaudible] he was like,
you were,
you were such a bitch.
Ah,
you just don't want to look at yourself objectively.
Know whatever day.
We'll bitchy.
I can be a little bitchy when somebody says something stupid.
I'm going to say I'm going to call it out.
I don't know.
I think I'm just being very blunt.
If that makes me bitch than fine.
Well,
it's
a good thing to do occasionally,
but it's also a good thing to just internalize and laugh at.
I do that too.
You could have two different reactions and do,
you can be around someone who's saying really annoying shit and just focus on it
and get fucking crazy and go Jesus Christ.
Or You could just go,
yeah.
Sometimes I'll sit back and laugh at it just because it is pretty amazing.
Human folly is some of the funniest shit like that.
Just it's been around forever.
We were talking about Kenny powers yesterday,
how funny that character,
that character is because it's so subtle and close to reality and we almost
David Koresh lives in a way.
That's one of the reasons why it's so funny because human like Hubris and folly,
it's like,
and people be just being dumb asses.
Some of the most amusing stuff for us because we can relate.
Yeah.
I think especially now with like technology,
I just think everyone's just a little brain dead inside now.
You know?
It's like everyone's on their phones.
Everyone's,
you know,
I look around,
like I'll go to a restaurant or something and I'll see like a whole family on
their phone and it just blows my mind.
I'm just like,
wow,
I'll see kids.
I'll see like three year olds with iPads and iPhone fives and stuff and I'm just
like,
whoa.
Did you see that history in pictures thing that was going around the Internet a
couple of days ago of all the people on the train with the newspapers,
that was amazing,
wasn't it?
Beautiful,
beautiful caption was something like technology is making us antisocial and then
it showed all these people from like the black and white 1930 train.
Yeah.
And everyone's got a paper in front of their face and now it's,
everyone's got a phone and the fucked,
must it have been back then to get your news from some stupid piece of paper
that William Randolph Hearst edited.
I mean,
that's how marijuana became illegal in the first place.
She gets William Randolph Hearst got ahold of,
uh,
this,
this idea to stop marijuana,
stop hemp production from being made after that call.
The decorticator,
I mean,
William Randolph Hearst who ran the fucking newspapers,
at least people right here,
they're probably re reading 80% bullshit.
They do well in the New York Times today.
I read it so hard to get information back then.
I read if I beat a Bailey fucking awful cartoons.
You remember how dark knight or whatever unfunny which one?
Like family circus,
the funny pages.
Oh yeah.
You would read them and go,
this is dog shit.
There's never been a worse version of the comedy.
There's never been a worse like depiction of the comedy arts manifested in a,
in a,
you know,
in a final product.
Then cartoons,
like a funny pages like Annie and Kathy.
Remember Kathy Doonesbury Dude,
very fucking suck.
What was the like,
Oh,
you gotta watch Doonesbury kicked out.
Fuck out of here.
What are you talking about us?
Who's Binchy now?
You can't,
you can't make it funny.
It's not funny.
You can't do it.
I mean every now and then the,
the,
you know,
when they were funny,
he was funny when he was making fun of hunter s Thompson and like the 70s.
Marmaduke yeah.
Margaret,
get the fuck out of here with Marvin.
Somebody didn't just pay for Marmaduke.
Somebody made millions off of Pharma Dharma.
Dukie who was the one?
Um,
I love the far side though.
The far side was great.
Good.
Calvin and Hobbes was Kinda,
I kinda got into that one.
It was the one with the guy with the glasses.
Um,
Predator,
sexual predator.
Know a famous one.
God dammit.
I know what you're talking about.
Gilbert.
Dilbert.
Scott.
What was his name?
He like worked in the office.
I never read that.
He did an episode of News Radio and the guy who was the creator of Dilbert,
cause there's the little fat guy right with the glasses.
He was like,
let's do that heat.
This is what he looked.
He was like a little Humpty dumpty.
Yeah,
the double turntable mixer.
Do you like Djs Joe?
Um,
I don't really like electronic music that much.
It's not really my thing.
Yeah,
I know the gays are really into know.
You're just,
you're just pinning us up.
You're putting us in a category.
Garfield.
No,
but they were saying that.
Um,
have you ever done poppers?
Yes,
I have.
Like a lot of them.
No.
Why did you do poppers?
Because you've got to try shit.
That's a gay thing,
right?
No,
it's a thing.
I don't guys don't do pop,
you know what it is though.
It's like it's just a,
well they don't just how,
yeah,
I do Jalapeno poppers,
Jalapeno poppers for poor people.
Don't understand what you're talking about.
Non Drug users,
poppers or Amy [inaudible] we brought you on [inaudible] the fuck you going to
explain to people?
It's like,
well,
pretty much what it is is a VCR head cleaner and um,
it's like if you go into any shop,
like a sex shop or like,
Hey,
I'm like,
yeah,
like if you go into like a,
I wouldn't even say,
I don't know if I can name businesses,
but like,
um,
any sort of like novelty sex store or something like that,
they will have at the very front case,
they'll have these little vials and sometimes they'll be like,
oh,
a VCR cleaner because we all know we all still own VCRs.
Um,
so it's bath salts.
No,
it's not Bessel.
It's sort of a thing where does it make something illegal?
Because he'd say it's not for right?
Absolutely.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
It's like,
yeah,
it's a,
it's a cleaner or sometimes it'll have like a nickname too.
It like jungle juice or,
you know,
something stupid.
And what it is is like I've done it.
I,
I did it like once or twice,
but it's one of those things where it's like you,
you do it and it's like there's this crazy head rush in your body just gets like
really,
really hot and it only lasts for like 10 seconds.
I compare it to like whip.
It's if you've ever done whippets it's like that.
Okay.
So is this actual amyl nitrate or is this just some other kind of head rush?
Um,
they say it loosens up your butt and I don't know about that cause I don't,
I'm a top and
very specific rules.
Do you start out of top or is it like,
you know,
like you're an open miker you work your way up to being a middle act.
How does it work?
I'm topping tonight.
Oh Man,
I got a tight 30,
tight 30.
Um,
no,
it's,
I don't know.
I just don't like things up my bud.
But some dudes do some,
some deals.
You got to find what I'm there for.
That's what it's all about.
Life is all about
finding people who want what you need to give them.
Yeah.
I help people out.
My friend chuck,
he had this girl that he was dating and uh,
she,
all she wanted to do was suck his dick.
And I was like,
it's a dude.
You'd probably have a dude that's like pretending to be a girl.
He's like,
no man,
we,
I mean,
we had sex a couple of times.
He goes,
but her favorite thing was just,
just suck my deck.
And I was like,
that's so weird.
He goes,
yeah.
After a while it was kinda like,
I was like,
come on on of sacks.
And she's like,
no,
no.
I just want to suck your Dick.
And I was like,
did your pussy is mine or something?
And he's like,
no.
She goes,
she was just weird,
said she got more satisfaction out of sucking Dick.
Then she did a out of actually having sex.
We're all crazy busy.
There's so many.
I mean,
have you ever talked to Dan Savage?
Um,
Dan Savage?
Yeah.
No,
I know who he is though.
I mean,
he,
I love that guy to death.
I would just like a sex advice guy.
Right.
He's just the coolest dude ever.
I mean,
I would love to just like sit down with him and just brunch.
Just be like,
cause I think he's one of those guys who takes it to that next level.
What's so I don't,
I'm not really,
I just know his name.
Like the whole like gay rights.
He's like a huge,
like he's the,
it gets better guy.
Like he,
you know,
he's like a big campaign for like the LGBT movement and like equality and um,
he's just one of those guys,
he's the guy who liked,
coined,
uh,
Santorum,
Rick Santorum when he was an asshole or whatever.
He,
he,
he compared Santorum to like a frothy anal leakage,
whatever.
And so every,
like he coined the phrase Santorum and named it after Rick Santorum.
Like that kind of stuff.
I was like,
I love that stuff.
Is that Santorum guy?
A lot of people I went to after that car,
so many of them.
Did you see the whole,
like the Coca Cola thing?
Did you the the Superbowl commercial with that and what we were talking about,
they did the Superbowl commercial where they played America,
the beautiful and they sang America the beautiful and did it in different
languages.
They did it in Spanish,
they did it in like Hindu.
They did it.
And like,
you know,
all these different languages because that's what America is and you get all
these crazy people who were just like,
this is my country.
I'm drinking Pepsi now,
Hashtag Fuck Coke.
You know?
And it's,
it's,
it's embarrassing.
I mean,
I'm just like,
you have all these people you have,
and then there was like a gay couple in the commercial and everyone's like,
oh,
I'm not drinking that fag coke now.
It's like,
God,
that's why I was going to say like,
it's interesting,
like you through those together and you're right to do so.
It's like,
it's all intolerance.
It's all intolerance and ignorance.
The language and tolerance is just as bad as the homophobia is just as bad as
the racism is just as bad as that nationalism.
Absolutely.
It's just dumb asses.
Yeah.
You're right.
To throw them in together.
That's a,
that's an important distinction because it really is the same.
It's just idiots.
It's really the same.
What was the,
there was something else too.
Pop country ain't allowed a spate no ass bang.
Yo just pissed me off that whole,
the whole Grammy's wedding to that whole thing.
I actually knew one of the guys and the WHO got married at the grammys,
I don't know what you're talking about.
They,
there was like,
um,
they did the Macklemore's same love song for the Grammy's and like Queen Latifa
came out on stage.
Like she actually just walked out.
She didn't like come out.
But um,
she came out on stage and she is a minister and she married like 32 couples,
gay and straight.
It was just marriage,
just supporting equality and love and then,
you know,
it was actually really nice.
You just said like cuts to like,
who was it?
I'm trying to remember who it was.
Oh,
it was like Keith Urban,
just crying,
just bawling.
And I was like,
oh,
look at him,
look at that little guy.
And I'm immediately to Twitter.
They were like,
oh,
the Grammy's were great until the fans got married.
I'm like,
my God,
do you not like what's wrong with you?
Like who cares?
Is it bothering you that much that you have to take it to Twitter and hope that
someone,
and now the Twitter is doing it too.
And I think social media too,
they're taking like the most offensive tweets from people and like displaying
them,
like showing the ignorance.
It's like that lady who,
uh,
there's just like websites and stuff now that are not like buzzfeed and they're
just like,
look at,
these are the reactions from like,
right,
but it's horrible people.
Twitter's not,
no,
no.
It's like that one chick who was like the,
she was like a head of a company or something and she flew to Africa and she was
like,
she's from South Africa.
She's like,
well,
go on to going to Africa.
Hope I don't get aids.
J K I'm white.
And it's like,
why would you do that?
She's probably on a Xanax and she had a glass of wine,
lost a fucking Marvo South Africa flying to south APP.
She's flying to her hometown and she's in America with this like head of head of
something.
She was like some executive of some company and they were like,
well,
you got fired there.
Sorry about it.
It's funny.
If she was Ari Shaffir I'd been fine.
That's what the guard would have said.
No one.
Sure.
He's probably upset that I should have come up with dental.
My old man went to Africa before her.
I would have definitely said something totally should have done that drove.
Yeah,
I mean it's silly.
It's silly for her to do it,
but it's also silly for people to get upset.
It's a joke.
She's choking.
She's probably fucked up.
You know,
maybe she's good at her job and they're going to fire her just because she said
that she on that,
cause he was funny.
She got a little Xanax in her system,
had a couple of cocktails and thought she was hilarious.
I can't wait till I landed in African,
see my tweets.
Oh mg.
Am I right ladies?
I think it's so fun of higher.
God.
No.
Do I eat?
How do I eat?
Eat Now?
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm a disturbed that the amount of intolerance in this country still at the
level that it's at,
but I feel like we're at a turning point.
I really do.
I feel like there's a tipping point.
Like there's going to be like a lot of stupidity that comes along with the
tipping point,
like massive over sensitivity,
massive overreaction to things.
Especially like with,
people were joking around about things
that's apologize.
It need to apologize.
Yeah.
But ultimately I think like the climate is way different people way more
sensitive to things now than they were just a few decades ago.
Definitely more than even really even more than just a few years ago.
You know,
it's,
it's changed,
changed quite a bit.
And I think a lot of that is just the exposure to different people on the
Internet and when people,
um,
who don't get to interact with each other on a regular basis.
Like you don't get to interact with each other in real life.
Right.
But then you start to do it online.
Do you realize that this is just a bunch of fucking people,
people are people hiding behind the Internet?
Yeah.
And the idea that you can generalize like just on sight,
sight unseen,
just looking at someone or just knowing their lifestyle.
Like you can generalize what kind of a person they are.
That's just unbelievably ridiculous because you can't do that with straight
people are all straight people.
Great.
Okay.
Well what about all the straight serial killers?
What about on the straight rapist?
What about a straight Thies?
What about now you can't take team straight cause teams traits filled with
Douche bags.
Okay,
so what,
what team are you on?
You're on team people fuck face.
Okay then I'm on,
I'm on team people includes gay,
straight,
black,
white
and that's one of the things too.
I hang out,
I hang out with mostly straight people.
Like that's,
that's the thing.
And I actually feel lucky because I'm like wow.
I,
I remember when I first first started doing standup at like people were like,
I'm just going to do an ra voice type as well.
Cause it was him.
Oh,
so are you going to like,
we're going to like try and fuck me.
I'm like,
you're a six.
Like you're like that.
You're an la six,
you're like a,
you're like a North Dakota negative three.
Like I'm negative three and these worth less in North Dakota.
Yeah,
probably.
So it's more valuable in la.
It's more valuable than La.
Keep up here.
But uh,
why is that?
It's the juicing.
Nah,
I love Ari can be right.
But he was one of those guys.
It's not necessarily that it was like giving me a hard time,
but it was just,
I entered being funny,
but I entered into this boy's club,
you know,
and it was like,
it was one of those things were people were very weird.
Like they didn't know what to do with me.
And so I had to just like kind of just show them that I'm just me.
You know,
there will be
ever worry.
Sorry to interrupt you.
Do you ever worry when you're meeting people and they find out you're gay,
you're going to get a negative reaction?
I don't give a shit.
Right.
I think it's,
it's the same thing.
It's like,
oh,
you're,
you like a MMA?
Oh,
okay,
well,
um,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna go,
you know,
it's like,
not that,
not that that's the same thing,
but it's one of those things.
I'm like,
what I like is what I'm saying when I get off stage,
it's like,
I,
I get guys,
I'll get like the bro do too,
just like the old man was phony,
you know,
I'm like,
fuck,
you know?
Ooh,
maybe.
And uh,
um,
but it's one of those things where I'm like,
okay,
then I've done my job,
you know,
I get girls,
I get guys,
I got couples,
you know,
it's,
it's cool and you know,
yeah.
I know part of that,
what you're saying is that like,
someone who has a problem with you being gay,
who gives a fuck and you want to talk to them in the first place.
Right.
They just think it's like,
oh,
you have a problem with,
you know,
a black comic or you have a problem with the juke comic or a female comic or,
whatever.
It's like,
are you just have a problem,
you just need to go home and look at yourself in the mirror and take a nice hot
bath and listen to some shot.
Do you find a comics like are more accepting than regular people?
Like generally?
Yeah.
I I mm hmm.
I don't know.
There's a lot of ego involved.
Do you know what I mean?
So comedy,
comedy,
there's a lot of ego involved so it's,
it just depends,
you know,
hey,
he's getting laughs but it's cause he's all gay.
Yeah.
And then you have those comics who,
I mean,
I remember,
uh,
I've been brought up to like,
I don't stage before like,
okay,
you guys ready?
This next guy is a fag comic.
I'm like,
what the hell?
I've had that with some dude.
No.
Was it Tony?
No,
at squashing me trying to be funny.
Um,
I have no idea.
This was like,
this was a law.
This was,
this wasn't even at the store or the factory.
This was like,
are you sure you didn't have a popper and tell them that to say that.
I'm like,
Hey,
can you bring me up to this
hanging out with werewolves crumpled teeth running naked in the woods in Canada?
Oh God,
that was,
um,
yeah,
it's very more accepting and I think as a community,
I think it's way more accepting.
I grew up very religious and it was,
I really lucked out.
Really lucked out.
I lucked out growing up religious,
no,
I lucked out with a cool family and cool friends and like,
I never,
you know,
I never got bullied.
I mean,
I got called names and stuff,
but I never got into like a physical fight with anybody.
You always out?
No.
When did you come out?
The first time?
Uh,
um,
God,
it was,
I think,
hm.
19.
I think it was 19 and then I went back in and then I went back in and then I
went,
yeah.
And then I came out,
there was like four or five times.
There was a buy phase.
There was a,
what is that like when you're,
when you want to go back in.
So you come out and then you go back in.
Is it because you're embarrassed as well?
I got,
I got outed by somebody.
So get out of,
by someone that you had sex with?
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
Actually.
Yeah.
And then got caught by somebody.
Okay.
Yeah.
And so why is this so funny?
I just,
I've just never really told this story before.
You don't have no,
I mean it's fine.
It's,
it's whatever.
Shit.
Okay.
I just don't want to be the pressure gun.
No,
no,
no.
But it's just funny now thinking about it.
I was like,
God,
I was such an asshole.
Like I'm still dating this girl.
We never broke up.
She could be married with kids now when we were still technically dating.
How can you be technically dating?
You know,
I was with this girl and then we like,
um,
you know,
I had the,
I had one of those weeks where I was like,
what are these feelings?
And you know,
um,
hooked up with this guy who I was friends with and like my roommate walked in,
it was like boop.
And I'm like,
I bet he have any avenue.
And then I had no idea you were gay.
Well,
I mean everyone did.
And then like,
so it got around,
it spread like wildfire.
I mean,
it got to,
when you say like the roommate walked in,
like what exactly what you're engaged in when the roommate opened the door,
I was under the covers.
Oh yeah.
So you one of the controversy,
the roommate and the roommate told me the dude was cross eyed.
Ooh.
And he's holding onto the covers and near underneath it.
It was a lot of wiggling.
No,
you have an imagination,
Joe.
His toes are poking out.
The end us at the end of the then,
Ooh,
white knuckled.
Oh,
that's right.
They call me the destroyer.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
it's spread.
I mean,
it went to Europe like this.
This is a rumor that rumor went to Europe,
there was like a school abroad program and someone sent a postcard was like,
it's what?
It's what they're singing about Justin.
True.
It was like Jesus,
it was like a stone henge like postcard.
I'm like,
enjoy stone.
Henge don't worry about me.
Yeah.
Uh,
care.
And,
uh,
I mean this was back,
this was like the early 2000,
so it was like,
um,
it was a different time,
but at the same time it was,
it was,
I didn't,
I didn't have to worry about like,
you know,
I feel bad for kids today with like the cyberbullying and the,
the,
I mean even youtube comments,
like I have stuff on online like from,
you know,
from the laugh factor or whatever and it'll be like,
you'll have that one that's just like,
fag kill yourself.
I'm like,
cut Jesus.
What the fuck man?
I'm like,
no,
you kill your self.
Yeah,
buddy.
I'll show you.
Look.
Yeah,
look,
when you're 19 years old,
it's,
it's hard to figure out who the fuck you,
even though I tried to take on a bunch of different roles when I was 19 years
old,
I tried to pretend I was different things.
I tried to,
like,
I remember like I decided I was going to be a carpenter.
I fucking hated carpentry tree.
I did it for like a week and I was like,
what am I doing?
That's not what I want to do.
I'm pretending this is what I want to do for a living.
I don't want to do this for a living.
I need to figure out,
you know,
but I couldn't imagine what it would be like to like want to be something that
you're not or not want people to know who you are.
It was one of those days and I didn't have like a,
my family would never really like talked about sex and,
and I grew up in Texas and it was one of those,
uh,
San Antonio.
And,
um,
I just remember just me,
it was very religious.
Like we didn't talk about masturbation.
It was always like,
you know,
it was just like sex ed was all about like put a condom on and like everyone
giggled and like,
you know,
it was,
uh,
I think my sex talk even was like my mom just being like,
now a guy puts his penis in a vagina and it feels real good.
All right.
Has got to go,
you know?
And I was just like,
what the hell?
Did she just say cigarettes?
No,
she didn't smoke.
She smoked pot,
but she didn't spell it right.
Mom smoke pile.
Yeah.
Really?
She's a cool mom.
A ways.
Even when you were young.
Oh,
I'm sure there's stories that I hear about my mom recently and they're like,
Shit.
Like she,
uh,
she's five.
Two,
I'm like six,
three and so like I'm fucking giant.
Giant fetus just growing in that water bed and it must have banged her.
How big is your dad?
Yeah.
Six.
Three?
Yeah.
Six.
Three,
six,
four.
Yeah.
They fucking corn,
Italian corn fed Stromae and making him a Martindale.
Aw Man.
I just swam.
Just move bitches.
You got brothers and sisters?
I got two brothers and a sister.
Yeah.
How many of them are good?
None.
Zero.
How many of them are borderline?
Uh,
how many of them could be persuaded?
I don't think they could be persuaded.
I mean,
I mean what they were,
one of them was in the military,
so I don't know what the shit that he saw,
but uh,
I wouldn't think so.
There's a lot of gay sex in the military.
You know,
I think I'm not going to answer that with a yes or no.
I just think that a lot of people will do things when they're away.
Okay.
Right now people in Afghanistan or fucking taken off their headphones,
throwing them on the ground.
My brother was fucking hippie pod cab brother was sucking cock.
I don't care what the Fuck Justin Martin Dale says,
I'm over here fighting for freedom.
I know what my brother was in Kuwait.
My brother drove a tank.
Everybody say I respect the military.
No.
Hey Dick sick suck.
Suck.
I mean I think he told me that he almost got shot by a woman like,
like crazy stuff cause I mean it's one of those we didn't talk woman soldier or
like a woman.
Like I um,
she was dressed in civilian clothes and she like pulled out a gun and,
and his friend saw it and shot her in the head and saved his life.
Oh snap.
So I'm very grateful for that friend.
Cause that,
yeah,
I couldn't imagine that.
That's messed up.
So I applaud you guys over there for doing that.
Cause I cannot do that.
Especially with this hair.
Your hair's too good for Iraq.
Shit.
I could,
I would cry like a little bitch.
You would cry like a little bitch if you had to deal with some way,
shape yet.
War and shaving.
My God.
Yeah,
I would.
I'd go crazy.
I'd probably,
I'd probably kill myself.
I couldn't,
I say that,
but I couldn't.
I just,
I couldn't do that like that David Koresh video was enough for me because I just
kept hearing the babies and the women crying in the background and I was like,
I,
I talked to a dude at told me there's some gay shit going on on a navy boat.
He said there was a lot of gay shit going on.
Boats,
seaman.
Don't ask,
don't tell.
They had a,
a boat
filled with men.
It's all me.
I think.
I just think guys were just sexual beings,
you know,
it's,
they're gonna,
you know,
we're not going to talk about this,
you know?
Yeah.
Come on son.
You keep a secret first of all,
before you answer yes or no,
I want you to a little bit.
These lips,
her lips to have their own business and they understand how it works.
Okay,
now close your eyes.
Close Your eyes and touch my lips.
I'm going to fucking shave.
I'm gonna fucking Shit.
I'm just the future son mean.
Fill them up.
So think about if you don't let them get them all wet first of all,
now feel it.
Feel it.
Just kidding.
Justin hard.
Pretend that some wall men close your eyes.
Do you jerk off?
Yeah.
What a man hand you jerk off and I was like,
I was like so many guys are like turned on right now.
Just wrapping this lips.
Yeah,
at least three or four.
This is a lot of people listening.
There's people that get turned on from anything.
You've got nice science,
Joe.
Thank you very much.
I like them.
They helped me see
the kind eyes.
I'll get you some roses for Valentine's Day,
dude.
One 800 flowers.com click on the microphone.
Don't be scared and use the code word,
J r e n save yourself some cash.
Bounced.
Check.
I bow bow.
You're on the cover of a Huffington post right now.
Am I?
Or Huffington didn't gay what isn't you?
And that's that funny or die spoof.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Me and my buddies did a spoof on the show looking on Hbo.
What's it at?
How many hits is it have,
does it say?
No.
My friend drew druggie and Jason Loony,
uh,
myself,
my friend Jeremy did a spoof cause it's,
it's,
if you haven't seen that show looking,
it's on HBO and it's getting a lot of um,
heat because everyone's like,
oh,
this is stupid and this isn't a how gay people are represented in San Francisco.
It's actually decent show.
I went up,
what's the best representative of gay folks?
Remember a queer as folk.
Is that good?
Um,
yeah.
I mean that was more I think extreme cause it show,
I mean it was very,
it was very,
very,
very sexual and yeah,
dancing and,
and drugs and,
but it was,
the characters were great.
How sparks was one of the guys on the parks a straight,
which is fascinating.
Don't do that.
What don't you make that fucking incredulous?
No,
that's just my face.
I know.
What the fuck you now I know what the fuck you did.
Listen,
he is though.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Look at me anyway.
Okay.
We're good here.
I think we have enough information
about human language.
The human language has a lot of subtlety to it,
so one of the things that I find so offensive about people pretending that jokes
are statements is because just there.
What we did,
we transferred information very clearly between each other and most people
listening know exactly what the fuck do you said?
And they know that I know that.
You know what you know?
Yeah.
Boom,
boom.
I think he's,
he's a great guy.
He's a great guy.
He's very funny.
Good looking.
Very handsome.
He's into a lot of conspiracies.
How's parks?
Didn't you like it wasn't like a nine 11 guy,
was he got it.
Yeah.
I think he might.
I should be careful because I've been accused of that unjustly.
So what being a nine 11 guy conspiracy theorist for nine 11 but you buy guy that
I had on the podcast and I fucking told him to his face that I don't think it's
a conspiracy and he's still writing.
And I think it's a conspiracy because people are fucking with that.
Is that like they illuminati of conspiracy theorists?
It's just a convenient one because it was a conspiracy to commit the crimes that
were committed.
It was a conspiracy to fly planes into buildings for sure.
Someone conspired,
they took over airliners,
they,
they hijack them and they flew them into buildings.
That alone,
no matter who did it,
whether it was the government or whether it was like some,
whether it was Saudi Arabia,
whether it was the al Qaeda and the Taliban,
whoever did it,
it was a conspiracy.
100%.
Okay.
So let's just get that out of the way.
Nine 11 was a conspiracy,
but the people like the guy who ran out in the Super Bowl,
uh,
post super bowl interview and said not 11 was perpetrated by the government.
Those people are fucking wacky.
Oh yes.
All of that.
And yeah,
that's,
that's unnecessary.
Well,
the nine 11 truther is those people that run out.
You know,
the real issue with that is they don't know.
You don't know and you're saying that you don't know.
I don't think it was,
I think it's much more likely that what happened was the United States was
attacked by a bunch of fucking psychos and the government took advantage of this
attack in order to instigate or to initiate rappers,
some plans that they had already,
they already wanted to go into Iraq.
They'd wanted to go into Iraq for a long time.
There was a bunch of shit that they wanted to do.
They wanted to go in Afghanistan.
He couldn't figure out a way to justify it.
Now they had a locks lock,
tight justified reason for,
for going to these places that that's what I think happened.
Much more likely then the,
the thousands of people kept their mouth shut about organizing this horrible
crime that killed thousands of people and you know,
they,
they made the fucking,
the towers disappear.
I might fucking pot doctor man gave me a book.
I'm going to bring it in because it's so ridiculous.
He gives me this book about how nine 11 the towers were destroyed using Tesla
technology.
Oh,
right.
Tell him I go,
what?
Tesla magma like lava or something like,
no,
no.
Well there's thermite is the big one that thermite cuts.
You know they've tested positive for thermo,
but the problem is like when the aluminum melts at all the different particles
are inside these infernos like you're going to get thermite like compounds
anyway.
It's just burning so hot.
Well,
all that stuff that's in there and there's like all these pictures that they
point to,
these girders cut exploding.
You can see the line cut in the grid of what they noticed was all cut by welders
to to clean up the scrap like they have before and after pictures of those cuts.
Like there's a lot of misses
information and misunderstanding when it comes to a lot of conspiracy theories.
A lot of them,
a big percentage of them,
they're saying the Superbowl was rigged to [inaudible] must have been.
They're saying the Superbowl was rigged and the United States wants Seattle to
when the red hot chili peppers were bunked.
That's what they say too though.
That's a new one,
right?
Yeah.
That that was just today breaking news.
They weren't playing their instruments and red hot chili peppers fake the funk.
I'm sure there's a picture.
Yeah,
they said that the red hot chili peppers guitars,
we're not plugged in during the Superbowl performance set hurts.
My soul hurts my heart a little bit.
It really does hurt.
I just want to go.
How does that happen?
How does the red hot chili peppers ever get to a point where they're faking
print playing music?
I think what it is is that they actually can't hear when they're on that.
Around that many people would be impossible for them to actually,
yeah,
but they put it on your monitor is him.
Yeah,
but I think it's even La that loud that even that wouldn't even do anything.
Lotions and fireworks and is there a picture of this then?
It can't be any louder
other than the UFC.
Like when the UFC is going on,
I have headphones on it.
I don't,
I don't hear anything.
I can hear myself loud and clear.
They the one that people are screaming at the top of their lungs when a fights
going on and their feet away from me in an indoor arena.
That thing,
I mean the Superbowl might be more people,
but I couldn't imagine it would be louder,
especially without a roof.
I can't imagine how it could be louder.
I want to go to a UFC fight with you.
I think I haven't put that on my bucket list.
Yeah,
let me know,
man.
You never know what you never want to go to.
I watched that.
It's one February 2nd.
You want to watch some chicks beat the fuck out of each other?
I mean what?
Ronda Rousey and said,
wait a second.
It's okay.
22nd yeah,
let's go see some girls fight.
Well,
I will have to work,
but you may be able to sit and sit and watch a live tweet.
It can't sit with you and answer questions.
I have to,
I have to actually,
I saw that video of that guy's leg break and that,
oh God,
that was terrible.
It's rare to,
oh,
it was so gross.
Yeah.
Really unusual to have a break like that.
We've only had two breaks like that in the history of the UFC,
but there have been some and other organizations
very similar where you got in a fight.
Oh yeah.
Of course.
You were there when it happened.
Almost all the paper views.
Almost all of them and all of the Fox shows.
I haven't been on all the Fox sports ones.
I don't do those anymore.
But I do virtually every paper view.
Unless there's some something serious going on that I can't do it.
But,
uh,
that's the only the second time it's ever happened and they haven't happened to
a great champion.
Like arguably the greatest fighter.
I've said,
the greatest fighter that's ever lived to have it happen to him.
That's pretty crazy.
That's sucks.
It's a nice sport,
man.
You know,
the human body's just not designed for it.
It's all about compromising joints.
It's all about cutting off blood and sparking your fucking nerves with
concussions and stopping your brain functioning.
It's really a really crazy sport.
That's pretty intense.
Yeah.
But the,
the excitement that you get from that,
from a being so crazy,
it's like there's nothing like it in the world.
And the girls go that hardcore to fuck.
Yeah.
Neesha tape versus Ronda Rousey,
which was the last big women's title fight that we had was one of the best
fights ever.
It was great.
It was so much drama in it.
Nisha all,
my God ma almost got fully onboard once,
but because Rhonda beat her by arm bar in the first fight and uh,
she'd beat her by our,
by the second fight too.
But Meesha got out of this crazy locked arm by,
you knew it was over and she gets out of it and the crowd's going insane.
And it was just like,
first of all,
we're,
Rhonda made her sail through the air with judo.
I mean,
that was one of the beautiful things about the fight was not just a two chicks
were going at it and said,
Ron does technique is impeccable.
It's like it hurts her judo is just magnificent.
Like her technique when she throws people,
it's a fucking work of art because like me,
she had tried to grapple with her and Rhonda launched her through the air.
Not once but several times,
slammed her on her back and beautiful judo.
I mean world class,
judo in action.
Probably the best judo we've ever seen in the UFC,
you know,
in comparison like it relative to the,
to her weight class and her division and then her arm bar techniques.
The best in all of MMA.
That bitch is bad ass man.
She asked,
she's wicked.
She's like Chunley from street fighter.
Better,
better than a real person and she has a vagina.
I mean,
I've heard,
well you're talking about in the street front of the girl.
I didn't know his girl,
Charlie.
I Dunno.
She's the one.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Rhonda Rousey.
Tie that bitch up and not throw off a building.
Damn.
Well wait,
here's,
do they let them have long hair?
They have their hair.
I mean,
I mean I get to get the guys to watch and take.
Can't grab it though.
You can't grab hair.
No,
cause I would say that would be like the first thing.
You always see that like in a girlfriend or they just,
well you used to be able to do that.
Like a,
when hoists Gracie fought,
uh,
chemo.
That's one of the ways it fuck chemo up.
He uh,
he had chemo in his guard and it was just bashing him,
holding onto his fucking ponytail.
He got ahold of that ponytail,
just fucked him up.
That was one of the all time craziest fights ever in the UFC.
Cause Chemo was enormous.
She never had a ponytail to 30 to 40 solid muscle and hoist was like one 70.
She's David and Goliath Pajamas.
Hoists still beat him still.
Armbar disaster oyster is a bad motherfucker back then and still is.
But back then,
that was the guy that changed at all.
He came around and showed people what's up.
Wow.
But back then you could grab hair.
Girls are not allowed to grab here.
They can't cut punt either.
Cut Punt.
He can't,
I'm sorry you can't kick a door in the Dick.
Oh girl can't come on.
That's,
I'll call it that.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is a comedy podcast.
This is not what it's really called.
I learned a new word today.
The Joe Rogan podcast.
You,
uh,
you're not allowed to kick a woman in the groin,
but they don't have protection on like a man does.
Oh,
they don't work cups.
I don't think that we're anything pretty sure their job.
But your,
your Coke Torres,
I'm sure it's very sensitive.
If you take a hard knee either there'll be horrible oh,
Chihuahua.
But uh,
that's illegal.
It's illegal just like it is on men.
But what is interesting is,
um,
I don't believe that the breasts are off target just grabbed,
a lot of women will wear like a,
you know,
they were like sport broadly sport bras and,
but there's no real protection of the breasts.
I haven't yet.
That's a really good question.
Actually.
I need to know if women's breasts are a target and MMA is or over the rules.
Exactly the same.
Maybe I would think they'd have to like tape their nipples.
No,
no,
no taping of the nipples.
Okay.
Here's the question.
Is the January 17th the very recent question,
Ken,
should chest trikes be band?
So they're talking about banning them for more for women.
It makes sense.
Well they're saying that it depends if the girl has implants.
If you ever hit a girl in the Boob,
like accidentally they'll,
they'll murder you mean accidentally?
Well like,
like all that,
just slap him around and say he slapped me around and hit him in the face.
You've got to tit slap him.
But I mean like I've been like out and like have nudged.
Yeah,
they're just like sensitive.
That's why it feels good when you suck him striking.
The enhanced breast will most likely caused them to burst.
So they keep a list of natural and surgically enhanced pressed for their female
fighters.
So That's interesting.
So if a woman has a surgically enhanced breasts,
they,
I guess they have to make a a deal where the girl,
if she's going to fight,
you can't,
uh,
you can't punch your tense.
Well that makes sense.
You don't want to busted boob.
This might be bullshit though.
This is on a forum by the way,
but it's on the underground and mixed martial arts.com and those guys are
usually a guy named a gumball kid has the,
uh,
thing I get,
let's,
let's find out.
They have,
do they have a list?
He hit her in the boob and she just flies around the ring just like an old
balloons.
There she goes.
She's out.
Okay.
Do they have a list of enhanced breath for women's MMA?
Um,
no.
This,
I'll need to ask somebody.
This is,
this is too long of a Google search.
I need to call up a big John McCarthy or um,
yeah,
you can't,
can't kick the ball,
but you can grab it.
It's just weird.
Like you can grab that,
but guys do what they call an oil check.
Excuse.
Oil check is sometimes in the middle of the grappling.
The guy will literally have his fingers deep into guys asshole just digging in
there and you know,
it forces the guy to move forces to got to move in away to get away from that
grip.
And I don't see,
I don't think it's in,
I don't
think it's illegal.
It's not,
I don't think it's illegal in wrestling either.
I wouldn't start making MMA butt plugs.
No,
that would just shove something deeper in your ass and you have to have like a
protection.
But what if you don't love a flat?
But the problem is you need movement,
like need your ass needs to be able to move.
So anything that you do that would like protect your ass hole,
we restrictive.
It'd be like,
it would restrict your ability to move left and right.
It would be a messenger boy.
Yeah.
It would mess with your athleticism to our oil checks.
Legal.
What if it's like,
like this though,
like if it's as a flat
no sticking things in your ass.
So I need to find out if this is,
oh,
so what about the swan?
Ah,
I've got to go to the bathroom.
Like here's that.
Here's the one where he's checked.
Yeah,
dudes do this all the time.
Chris Tufts is in ski.
So I was on camera and I said,
oops,
wait.
He says,
oh look.
He even said something on that end of it.
Um,
one guy,
uh,
actually got a rape charge from a wrestling match.
Apparently.
What,
when was this?
17 year old Jerome hunt faces 21 counts of rape and attempted rape.
Each count carries with him up to 25 years in prison.
Hunt's lawyer Mike Butler crank claims that complaints came from fellow Parker
wrestlers who were simply victims of a legitimate wrestling move bottler.
Just file a motion to move the case of juvenile court on that court document.
He lays out a lot of information presented to the grand jury before they
indicted hunt on the rape charges while he's indicted on the rape charges.
Wow.
Former state champion wrestler.
Jerome Hunt's lawyer says that all but two of the incidents reported happened in
the Parker high school wrestling room before the practice.
During last year's wrestling session.
Before practice.
Before practice rape.
Yeah.
It possibly came from a wrestling move called a but drag or skinning.
Okay.
Before practice,
what is dragging before practice?
It's not something illegal or not being taught.
It's being taught all over one accuser even testified to a grand jury.
I didn't take it as a sexual move.
I took it as him just messing around La who?
Who charged him then a prude.
Hmm.
This is interesting because that is the oil check is like a legitimate wrestling
move.
If that's what he's doing.
It's like people have been doing whether or not you think they should be able to
do that.
I don't think they should be able to do that,
but people have been doing that for a long time.
Like an actual legitimate wrestling like bill,
look up oil check wrestling,
find a video for oil check wrestling because that's something that guys have
done like for a long time.
I mean,
I would even say that's like gladiator days.
I'm sure they did that it's not the most effective way to control whole
person.
So it's not like something that someone does for a long time or on a regular
basis.
It's just when you're in a match with someone,
what
you're trying to do is win.
And if you spend time fingering is,
but you could've been doing other things that would actually get you to win the
match.
So it's not like something that comes up all the time.
Yeah,
I call that a Friday.
But um,
some people,
uh,
you know some people who don't know wrestling,
who found out that this guy's oil checking people and you know,
maybe being a dick about it.
Hey,
Johnny's oil checking people.
No,
fine.
Just what is this?
No,
no,
no.
Not checking the oil crisis.
Oil check.
Image oil check.
Wrestling,
checking oil.
Just listening.
Google oil check wrestling.
Yeah.
I got some money.
That was about it though.
I'm going to but drag you so you ain't safe.
Yeah.
Si.
Totally legal.
See how he's doing this and the referee's not getting angry at him and no one's
going to jail.
See this is,
it is actually illegal wrestling move.
That guy putting his hands in.
That guy's an asshole.
Like that is totally legal.
Not only is it totally legal,
it's so common.
Who made this video?
Like who,
who is like,
you know what I'm going to do today?
Like I said,
it's,
it's common,
but it's not the most common thing
like wrestling.
It's all about though.
It makes sense.
It's not the best way to control a guy all the time though.
So when it does come up,
guys do it,
but it's not like the only way to do it.
And it's not like if you,
if you concentrate on that when you should be doing something else,
you're going to lose the wrestling match.
So it's not,
he's,
what he's doing is using it as a whole.
He's literally trying to grapple by holding onto the guy like that.
He's not necessarily cycle.
He might be sexual or you might also be trying to inflict pain and discomfort,
but it's been going on forever.
Oh,
those damn oil checkers.
I sort of take this one kid and calm a rapist for that stuff.
But the other thing was then said Doris before practice.
That's a problem that before practice that that disturbs me.
Like,
wait a minute,
wait and wait a minute.
Like hours before practice,
like five minutes before practice.
Or you're warming up in the locker room like,
hey,
check this out.
You're going over techniques.
What is the exact,
what exactly is going on and how many counts does it say?
Like it wasn't just one person.
I think they said like 40 Jesus.
Yeah,
it's 40 people or 40 40 a churches.
Well,
I'll read it again.
I shouldn't talk about this kid.
And by the way,
this was a several years ago,
2006 actually,
but I'm 21 counts.
Wow.
Yeah.
That if,
if you know,
I don't know what that kid did,
so I'm just talking about in my ass.
But if the kid did what's in those videos,
you better go watch those videos because there's videos of people doing that,
but drag or oil check forever.
It's been going on for as long as he's been wrestling.
It's just not the most effective thing to do always.
It's not in every match,
but shit,
it's pretty fucking common.
Yeah.
You know,
and then they butt plugs.
That doesn't help,
dude.
Stupid idea.
It's just going to go deeper in and you bleed.
It's not going to stop the guy from holding onto it.
Get a little tail on the end.
Yeah.
It's God.
Good idea.
Make it a decorative,
but pull that out and the guy gets embarrassing.
It's happened.
A loud pop pop.
It's like,
sorry about that.
Uh,
I take that,
oh,
there's me,
but did I hear that?
Um,
Brock Lesner is thinking about coming back to the UFC.
Yeah.
That's bullshit.
Yeah,
that's bullshit.
They,
there's one hype story when they were trying to hype it up,
uh,
because the WWE was saying that Brock Lesnar was in Vegas.
They may might have big announcement,
but it's really just a publicity move to talk about Brock Lesnar's wrestling
appearance.
So there was a little bit of hype on that.
Some guys tweeting me that the,
but drag does not go into the butthole.
Um,
yes it does,
sir.
Sometimes drag does not go into there saying it's a,
there's a nerve back there pulling.
Yeah,
you're right.
But tell me the dude's don't sometimes put fingers in people's assholes.
Hey,
if I had,
if I can for sure,
dude,
cause I've had it happen.
So shut your mouth.
Don't tell me that oil checks don't go in your asshole.
I've had it happen.
Sneaky.
Creepy fingers.
Do's,
oil.
Jag,
you on a,
on a graph you're going to like,
just rub it like around,
you know it's,
there you go.
You go in.
It's not like,
oh,
I'm sorry there.
There's different people.
Look at this.
This is a nice one right there.
That's
definitely now those women,
is that Bobby?
Yes.
It's a woman.
Oh,
it is a woman.
That might be Felicia.
Oh,
I don't know who that is.
It might be my friend Felicia.
She's a bad ass grappler.
Okay,
that's fine.
She
is not right.
These are the,
uh,
that guy's an asshole.
Yeah.
That,
that's the oil wrestling that like Russian oil.
Respill Turkish,
Turkish wars.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Anybody who says it doesn't go in your asshole shut it.
He's clearly looking at that and just being like,
you fucking well,
you know,
it doesn't always go in.
Sometimes it just hits the taint sometimes.
Uh,
it's just that that would hurt.
That would hurt.
Got a good grip on the upper deck and it doesn't actually get in the asshole in
the lit up,
pulling the lit up on the macaroni and cheese container.
Just get the steam out.
Yeah,
just Tupperware in that motherfucker.
But sometimes it goes in the asshole.
There's a lot of fucking butthurt wrestling guys out there that are arguing with
me right now on Twitter.
We just showed you photos.
You fucks.
You're in denial.
There's a lot of guys who have had their assholes finger who were like,
thank you Joe for speaking up.
Bullshit did even go,
gosh,
it can't go in,
dude.
It's a trap.
My holes like a bank vault.
Nothing's.
Then you might be knocking on the door.
You can knock on my door.
Does that mean you sleep in my house?
No,
it does not mean you sleep in my house.
You just knocking on my door.
You can't get in.
I think it's time.
If you have had your butthole invaded by finger to come out and shows the brown
stuff,
fish of security,
nothing.
Nothing gets through.
It's tight like that fucking went event horizon when it opened up the time for
favorite scary movie ever.
That's my favorite scary movie of all time.
I'm so glad you said that.
Fucking good,
scary,
terrifying movie.
Whew.
Yeah.
The idea that they run into hell.
Ooh
enough.
Brian enough.
E and u f.
F.
What are you showing more guys with hands?
Dude's ass holes.
I think we get it.
Yeah.
Brian,
it happens.
Wrestling fans.
I know you don't like to believe it happens,
but it happens.
Oh yeah.
That was real too.
It's all real.
That's different.
That's just two men standing their ground with their lips locked and trying to
gain an advantage.
Making Valentine's Day plan.
By the way,
that White Guy,
one
white guy won that one as much to the dismay of black people everywhere.
Should have,
but check them much to dismay of Anderson Silva fans.
Much dismay of people don't like wrestling or checks,
oil checks,
drags,
but tracks.
I'm sure Chris Weidman has been oil checked some time in his life.
Last name like Weidman is how you make an animal like that.
Why?
How dare you?
What is this a parody?
Can we play your parody video?
It's called not looking,
not looking as fake.
Brian Stout,
what Jesus buying believes everything.
Twin Towers.
Fucking black helicopters.
That's just naked.
So this is a parody of what's the show called?
Names.
[inaudible] hit series looking and we did a hit series.
I never know what's on the third episode.
Yeah,
say it's a hit series,
but that's my friend drew and a WHO's a funny guy from the Groundlings and we
did an la spoof because of the San Francisco trailer or the trailer they do for
this one.
Oh,
I can't play the San Francisco one.
They're all just like,
it's so weird being in your thirties like one of them was like,
what's uncircumcised mean?
And I'm like,
what?
Where are you're in San Francisco and you don't know what uncircumcised means.
So we did a spoof on it.
It's like a minute and a half and it was,
we had a lot of fun doing it.
It's on funny or die.
How many,
what's it called?
What's the name of it?
That's it.
Um,
if someone,
oh,
not looking.
Hey guys.
Oh,
the audio cutout did.
Yeah,
but I love this song.
Now the audio cut out.
What do you mean the words?
Oh,
there it is for your body.
That's the guy from Nashville,
the series
morning here.
This might be something that people have to see.
Yeah,
you got to see it.
Yeah.
Montage walk.
Are you point?
Yeah.
I'm hearing just one day to Lucia if I should be clenching my butthole right
now.
But the visuals that go along with this audio,
it's,
it was fun though.
And it's getting,
it's been on like it was on Huffington post this afternoon.
It's like kinda crazy.
It's weird.
People who are Mike mildly homophobic because they're listening to that.
They would wonder whether or not this should clench.
Oh,
episode.
There's Iraqi soldiers pissed off or
Iraqi,
not American soldiers.
I don't give a fuck.
Okay.
Team America.
Do you think at pissing off,
do you think of pissing off a lot of your listeners know?
Okay.
No.
Well listen,
I piss off by the first gay on this podcast.
Todd glass.
Benard I love Melissa.
Melissa Etheridge,
Melissa Etheridge.
Who else has been guiding?
It's been on um,
Brian Dunning,
but for other reasons,
just being gay.
Yeah.
Wow.
Oh
well I'm a cool game.
So,
oh,
I'm this guy.
What feminists guy.
Oh,
buck angel.
Angel Porn Star.
We got him.
But no,
the,
the one that rape culture guy.
Oh,
he's not gay.
How dare you?
He's married.
So was that the one you got into a fight with?
No,
no,
no.
I've had two arguments ever on this whole podcast.
One was Brian Duffy,
you know,
it was Jamie.
But do the Jamie argument was,
it was based on,
um,
Daniel Tosh and Daniel tosh getting in trouble.
Yes,
I remember.
I actually saw that episode.
I've watched that one cause that was so it's when he,
when he made that rape joke and he was just
trying to defend it or it was for it or something like that.
And you guys just buried him to the ground,
didn't you?
He didn't make a rape joke.
He was,
well he did in the past,
but it was a,
it was tosh saying a rape joke.
Some woman,
the story was touches at the laugh factory and he asks like,
uh,
what do you guys want to talk about?
And some guy yells out rape and then Tasha is going like,
what is funny about rapists?
You know,
like is it the humiliation?
Like what do you think 20 about rain?
And you know,
he's just trying to make fun out of this and someone when it goes,
actually nothing's funny about rape.
And he goes,
wouldn't it be funny if five guys raped right now?
That's right.
I remember that.
And then of course the whole crowd laughed cause it's a hilarious thing to say.
But this woman wrote a blog,
you got all these people freak out as a blogger.
And I wanted him to apologize.
And Jamie took the side of the heckler and,
uh,
I,
you know,
I said,
that's ridiculous.
It's so obvious that it was a joke and there's all this idea of trigger
warnings.
And the,
a real problem with that show wasn't,
it wasn't even the two people disagreed.
It was like his depiction of it afterwards was,
you know,
I think people forget how things actually went sometimes and then they start,
they give their version of it and then,
you know,
get to go back and look at the actual words that were said and then their
version of it and it makes them look deceptive.
Right.
Sometimes it's not even that they're actually deceptive.
What it is,
is that there's a lot of people out there that are this Brian Dunning guy that
we're talking about that we had that podcast with his depiction of our podcast
and me being a nine 11 truther when I clearly said I wasn't as clear as
possible,
but he still thinks that somehow or another,
it's a supporting,
some sort of,
um,
some sort of conspiracy theories.
What are you throwing up that's distracting me?
That was the Jamie kills things.
The latest CD.
He has a track called dude,
Bros get super mad when you say rape is bad.
Oh wait,
he's still on it.
He won't,
he won't let it go.
Yeah,
he says,
I listened to it.
You don't buy it.
You just listen to it on Spotify.
I don't want to hear it.
Who Says Dude Bros?
Well it's,
that's a way of diminishing anybody who has a contrary opinion,
but the idea being bros like men who uh,
or like idiot proof and masculine,
the rest of new way to diminish people's opinions like that.
Your Bros.
Oh,
there they are.
All bros.
Yeah.
This is what the type of thing that people do if they want to diminish you
without just talking about what the actual subject is.
It's not the people get upset if you say,
don't say rape.
That's not what it is.
People get upset if you're hypocritical.
People get upset if you tell a distorted depiction of the actual events and make
it so that it favors your point of view.
And then you were attack and victimize.
People have a real problem in this country with people that play the victim
role.
And um,
a lot of people do it by default and they might not even realize they're doing
it by default,
but they do.
They go into this,
you know,
I was victimized.
These guys got mad at me because I did this.
It might not be that you might've done something annoying.
You know,
there's,
and it's also like,
why do people relish?
So like being in these disputes and these debates with people where they,
they feel like they're going to lash out and right or wrong,
because nobody wants to be wrong.
No one wants to be wrong.
Yeah,
that's true.
Because it's embarrassing.
It's belittling.
It's,
you know,
you definitely right there,
people will fight to prove how right they are.
But the problem is when you do that,
if you fucking,
there's a recording of you being wrong.
God Damn,
that makes you look bad,
Brian.
Dunning's God damn,
that makes us look bad.
It makes you look bad.
Just it's bad for you.
It's bad for your thinking,
it's bad for your mind when you give a distorted depiction of the events and
people can clearly see that they go,
oh,
this guy's brains broken,
right?
This guy is so warped by ego.
He doesn't see what actually happened.
And it's clearly still not over it.
And still like Jamie.
Yeah,
Jamie's a comic.
You like Jamie's also a progressive guy and he's trying to do the right thing.
And I,
I don't,
I don't have any problem with Jamie.
I like him.
I really do.
And he's a,
he's an odd guy.
We don't agree on a lot of things,
but I think he's a good person.
I really do.
I just think that like these depictions of a,
of this,
the scenario,
it's like very,
there's like this a very progressive point of view that is like very rigid.
And then there's this,
uh,
this other point of view that either is like super douchey masculine that hates
the progressive point of view.
And then there's moderates that sort of get lumped into that Super Douchey Matt
Macho frame of mind just because they disagree with like the Uber Progressive
Point of view.
And I don't think it's that black and white,
you know,
I think especially with something like rape jokes,
like all rape jokes aren't funny.
The only rape jokes that are funny or funny ones,
just like all murder jokes aren't funny.
The only funny murder jokes are funny murder jokes.
That's the ones that are funny.
Just like all jokes about fucking ice cream aren't funny.
And if you tell me a bad joke about ice cream,
it's more offensive than a good rape joke.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Sorry,
I'm sorry the people don't want to hear that.
But I see oak about race.
See what you're saying.
That he was a part of life and it's not a good part of life.
It's awful.
And it's not something you should promote.
But the idea that saying a joke about rape somehow another promotes rape is
crazy.
It's a joke.
And the idea that it becomes a part of this culture.
Yeah.
No,
it's crazy too.
It's not,
it's not a culture of rape.
There's assholes that commit rape in our culture.
Yeah,
yeah.
I do a joke about,
uh,
having a rape whistle and,
it didn't work.
No one will to know it does like it because it's a very visual thing,
like a talk.
It's,
it's a,
it's you have to get checked,
man.
See it.
But,
um,
but I do,
I act it out.
Like I,
I grab it off my nightstand and I just go,
okay.
And it's a visual and everyone dies.
Guys,
girls.
It's one of those things.
And I'm like,
but that's the thing,
I'm blowing a rape whistle.
I never get like that,
like backlash.
I mean it's,
anything's a joke now I get offended.
I mean people ask me,
cause a lot of people talk about like gay people on stage and gay jokes and
stuff like that.
And I don't get offended at them because I know it's part of the business.
It's one of those,
I mean,
how many times do I hear the n word on stage?
How many times do I hear everything?
It's part of who we are.
I will if I,
if it's a bad joke and if I think it's unnecessary,
yeah,
I'll,
I'll say something and be like,
hey,
that kind of didn't work.
But at the same time,
I think those jokes are kind of
okay.
Winding down now.
Cause I mean if you say anything about,
I mean I've heard,
I mean I've heard the word fag on stage and like you'll hear that the audience
just quiet,
just a death eater just sucked out all the life they were very aware of.
So that's Kinda cool cause I like that whole progressive mentality.
I mean,
you can say gay people,
you're whatever,
but it's like,
it's like you can't say that word now.
It's like,
ah,
if Kennison did that old bit that he did about aids,
do you remember that?
Kennison bit.
Vaguely.
I,
he had a bit about aids.
Um,
it was,
uh,
it was really controversial.
Yeah.
And it got him in a lot of troubles with his second album and he was like,
just because a few fags fucked a monkey,
I got to wear a condom
and you know,
but that was the time.
That was the time.
But it was um,
you know,
he was talking about how aids is,
uh,
you know,
the age is a gay disease.
Like they say,
hey,
it's a heterosexual disease.
Straight guys can guide to straight guys can dice the die to Sam.
And he was like,
name one fucking guy.
It's not our dance.
Just cause a few facts.
Fuck dumb monkey.
That's good impression.
It wasn't really good.
The person,
it's not that good.
It'd be better if I heard them.
There's a dude that does the stern show used to do it.
Oh,
Craig glass.
Yeah.
He does the most insane.
This impression.
You think Kennison is in the room.
Like if you closed your eyes you would really Kennison it's,
it's,
it's really quite freaky.
That guy does spooky impressions.
But,
um,
yeah,
people are definitely becoming more and more sensitive to these things.
People were upset at me this weekend because I said that I was a retard.
Uh,
during a broadcast.
I,
I was talking to you a favor.
Uriah faber fought,
he fought Hanan Barao for the bantamweight title and Browse one of the best
fighters in the planet and Brown,
it hurt your right and your rise as well.
But he hurt Uriah pretty bad in the first round and the referee stopped the
fight early.
Uriah was still trying to recover and he was hanging on.
He was given the referee the thumbs up telling me it's okay.
The referee stopped the fight and the crowd went nuts and bolts like it's over.
It's over.
But he was,
he was definitely hurt,
but it was a premature stoppage and most people agree that it was a big mistake.
So,
uh,
I was in the octagon and I was interviewing your Ryan.
I felt real bad for the guy.
I mean,
this was like a huge opportunity for him.
The fight got stopped early and he's known as being like a really tough guy.
They could bounce back and you know,
he just,
you could see like,
he really felt disappointed that the fight ended the way it ended.
And,
uh,
he was bringing up his teammates and uh,
I said,
what about Chad Mendez who was actually in the wrong way class?
And he goes,
he's in a different way cos I go,
I want to like,
you're right.
I'm a retard.
That's what I said while I was interviewing him,
when people would just like,
you know,
I guess I shouldn't have said no,
you shouldn't say that on television.
It's not,
you know,
quote unquote professional.
Um,
I only said it because I was,
you know,
I was flustered.
I was into this thing where I felt bad for the guy and I didn't know what to say
and mean.
What am I going to say?
The Guy,
the guy just had this dream that got me 34 years of age and I did say the wrong
name.
I did,
I did give the wrong way class house,
which is very unusual for me.
I'm usually really good at that stuff.
Uh,
but you know,
you can only have so much information in your fucking brain and sometimes it
gets shuffled around and sometimes it gets shuffled around on the fly,
on television and you fuck up.
So I call myself a retard because I'm a self deprecating person.
If everyone lost their mind,
well there's some people got upset at it.
I shouldn't have used retard and they're right.
I absolutely shouldn't have.
You're,
you're 100% right.
I apologize for using it,
but I do use that word all the time.
And um,
I use that all the time too about myself and it's self deprecating way.
I could call myself an idiot.
The idea that I'm calling myself retarded as if retarded a disease like down
syndrome is the disease.
I'm not saying I have down syndrome,
I'm saying retarded.
Like I'm slow.
Like I'm,
I mean that is not an technical medical term.
And when I'm using it to describe myself in a derogatory manner of being an
idiot,
I'm not going to listen to you.
Okay.
I'm going to keep calling myself a retard,
I think.
I think that is so silly that we're getting so fucking minute with our,
our fucking criticisms of people.
You can't call yourself a retard is a new one.
It's one thing.
If you call yourself a nigger,
I be like,
you might not want to do that.
Yeah.
It seems like people can get offended.
I just like Mike.
My balls just went inside me when you said it was ruined my own argument.
Maybe I just through my own argument,
there's a new argument right there.
I did didn't,
I kind of crushed my own argument in a way I did.
Why?
Why should I be able to say call myself a retard?
Retard is offensive to call someone else a retard.
Is it though the word?
The words totally taboo.
Now maybe there's a new one.
There's the new word transgender.
No.
Well,
yeah.
Twink no,
I remember that.
You can call and got in trouble for saying Twain.
You can say twink.
Yes you can.
You're going to get me in trouble.
Everyone all at once.
Um,
Andy Cohen from Bravo Rao.
Andy,
come on.
Who is gay by the way?
He was telling me now,
but it's for the people who don't know.
Yeah,
Andy.
Yeah.
Twink and he had apologized.
That's bullshit.
I call,
I mean I got my brother Andy on this one.
I mean that's,
that's,
that is not,
that is a group of people that,
that name has been,
was developed for the gay community.
That's like a twink is,
is there's twink and bear.
Then you shouldn't say bear then you shouldn't say odder than you shouldn't say
his lap.
Come back.
I don't know what there is him saying.
Twink like a black guy using the word nigger.
No,
no,
it's not twink tweak is not offensive.
No,
it's Kinda cute.
I get,
you know,
I get called,
I like to do is I'd like to think of myself as an older twink.
I'm a Twang call.
You're told Twan Twinkies.
I'm actually no animal.
If anybody from the death squad family could classify me as an animal,
I will.
I will go through your choices and establish myself as starting that.
No,
but Gabori cabaret.
CITA bay.
What precious.
The girlfriend,
precious Gabba cabaret said,
obey my friend.
Fred would know that by the way.
Well not really.
I have some of my friends who call her Anamae Cinnabon,
which I think is actually kind of a,
a fun name.
But she got into trouble because she used the word trainee repeatedly on our,
I think it was our scenario,
but she,
she was just dropping it left and right.
And that's one of those words to me,
cause that's,
I think that's the new word that everyone's like,
you can't say that now.
You can't say that word.
I've been hearing that word for years.
I've heard transsexual people,
transgender people using that word I've [inaudible] but they're trying because
it's one of those things were the transgender community trying to make a very,
very poignant part and just be like,
we are part of this community.
You know,
we're tired of it.
One of my,
one of my,
uh,
friends who was on Rupaul's drag race,
we actually did that podcast with,
uh,
with red band.
When Raja was it guests,
one of her drag queen contestants named Carmen Carrera,
who was gorgeous Gore.
Like,
pull up a picture of Carmen Carrera right now.
Don't do it.
It's got my sunglasses.
No,
no,
no.
That you turned to stone.
There is,
she's not Medusa.
If you're a straight guy.
No,
you're going to be like,
but I'm transgendered is now picketing.
Not Picketing.
That's a horrible word.
She is trying to get Victoria secret to make her the first transgendered model.
So I think,
but I don't think the word,
I don't,
I,
I hear the word training.
I've heard,
I've heard drag queens call each other trainings.
I just think it's,
everyone's being very,
very centered.
Well,
people love to call you out on shit and they love to get you in something that
you were wrong.
That's a transgender chick.
Yeah,
Carmen Carrera.
She's amazing.
I love her.
Students have kind of a thick neck though.
Yeah.
But gorgeous.
I mean how deep their voice,
no,
it sounds like a girl.
She is a,
she's postop.
Um,
better.
No,
pre,
uh,
no,
no.
It has has boobs and everything,
but I think is,
I don't know if it's had this,
if she's had the surgery or not,
the whole sheet on her.
If they haven't had the operation instead of like being a glass half empty,
let's just call it the full package.
I've heard a lot of people are into that.
The full package.
Yeah,
I bet there's a lot of anime porn online with the full package.
Giant Dicks,
big fake titties.
And it's like,
what are you trying to fucking do?
What is going on and your seller,
what's your mixed message?
I know,
yeah,
she's stunning waiver.
We had a,
um,
a transgender woman on the man show and we had this thing,
her name was vanity.
We had to gea and vanity,
uh,
both very nice people,
but the,
the vanity chick,
we had this box attached to dude's dicks and the box was a,
let's say he goes to show you how stupid like sensors and like standards of
practices people are.
Doug and I,
we created this game show called make me hard.
And the,
the game show was you would,
uh,
you would have a box over your Dick and then we'd have a bunch of things happen
in front of you.
And then,
you know,
we obviously control whether the bulb lights up or not.
So like,
you know,
we have like a women dancing around.
Nothing.
A dude eaten a banana.
Obtaining ticking the box goes is like,
pretend you go.
That's cool.
That's good social experiment.
But it was fake.
It was obviously just a real one.
But here's where it gets fake.
Vin.
This vanity chick comes out and she's gorgeous.
I mean,
she's like a 10 and uh,
she's putting whipped cream on her nipples.
The Guy Sucking it off.
Everybody's going crazy,
but the light is not going on.
Then she pulls her pants down and she's got a deck and the whole crowd sees it
and goes fucking crazy.
It was the loudest sound of disappointment I've ever heard collectively from 300
men.
Oh,
and of course,
that's when the light goes off.
This is dicks.
Hard as a rock,
right?
It's silly.
It was silly.
But,
but it's true.
I've heard some,
I've heard a lot of stories about people who are into that,
like straight bros.
What was silly was that you could say,
you could have this girl pull your dick out.
Okay,
but what you couldn't do is say the word hard.
They wouldn't remove hard.
They wanted it to be make me stiff.
They made us change the title stiff like make me hard.
It's just too offensive.
We're like,
what are you talking to?
If I think make me stiff is way more offensive than I just want to change.
So just morons,
moron.
Talk.
Just dummies.
Who want to go?
What about move this around.
I want the lamp to be here.
Ooh,
I will.
If the room didn't have the lamp pair,
the room wouldn't be the room.
I put the laughter in the room.
They were going to have no lamp and I made them put the lamp there.
I've walked in that room and I said,
it needs a lamp.
Well,
if you've always been good at figuring out what's wrong,
needs lamp,
that's my skill.
I might not be funny,
but I know where the funny belongs.
Can't say hard Yancy.
Yeah,
free.
God made a batter.
Who maybe better.
I put my greasy little fucking chubby doughnut fingers all over everything and
the butts oil check the oil check.
Yeah.
The whole show.
But uh,
the point is everybody in the audience before she pulled her dick out,
everybody in the audience thought it was the hottest bitch on the planet.
Yeah.
Beautiful Legs and beautiful face.
Long heroin.
Yep.
Boom.
Whoa.
Ooh,
epic thunder.
Ooh.
The schlong heard round the world.
Yeah.
But uh,
you're,
you're definitely right.
And there's something weird with the,
uh,
the morphs,
the anime morphs giant Dixon big fake titties and having sex with women.
It's like what,
you know,
having sex with guys that too sometimes.
Yeah.
But having sex with everybody,
everybody's having sex.
That's just one of those things.
Wow.
That,
wow,
I've got a date tonight,
so boom,
boom ass to mouth.
Ever.
Justin.
Ah,
AH,
MMM.
No.
I have all that information.
The boys got to have secrets.
It's got to be,
look at it as the green light goes off and red bands corner.
He's a child.
Trust me.
I know you don't want to take questions on that guy.
Yeah.
Do you mean?
Do I ever human centipede?
What is the policy?
Was the policy in the gay community as far as like outing people that are in the
closet,
is it considered to be like a Douche move is it's considered to be lots of good
question.
Like say if you know this guy and uh,
he's pretending to be straight and maybe he has a few boyfriends,
but he says a few homophobic things.
Try to throw people off the trail then.
Is it the green light because it says homophobic things?
Yes.
Dan,
it's a green light.
I'll say.
Oh,
that's a really good question,
Joe.
That's a,
that's one of those things where
it's like,
uh,
my,
my philosophy is let everybody,
everybody has their own journey that every wouldn't do what they want to do.
That's a good philosophy.
It's not my time to say who.
I mean I love you.
If I'm a friend of yours,
I will love you no matter what.
That's just the person I am.
That's the person I won't catch eat and babies.
I'll beat the fuck out of here because I love a good bake and baby love a good
bacon.
Maybe
it's everybody's journey is different,
whatever.
But it's one of those things where it's like if you,
if if,
if you've got some demons or you've got some issues and you're coming after my,
my people and then I know some things I'm just going to be like,
all right.
You know?
Yeah.
That's how I see it's game on.
That's how I feel about the whole outing thing.
It's sad and the,
at the end of the day it's just sad.
It's definitely an,
it's so pitiful to have like tip to hate on a certain group of people.
And when you're doing this,
when you're part of that,
like it's,
it's just like what?
Well they're just self loading and the trash throw people off the trail.
It's pitiful you ever talked to,
I mean it's so common.
Like you ever talk to girls that are sluts girl and I want to say anything
wrong.
I don't want to slut shame but sluts,
love to talk shit about other sluts.
Okay.
And by the way,
I'm a fan of slots.
I love,
again,
I shouldn't say the word slap maybe is retard and training.
We would all be lumped in together with twink.
Um,
but there's like girls who will like,
do you know wild sexual shit?
They'll one of the first to talk shit about other girls doing wild sexual shit,
whore,
whore.
And then it's like you look over and there she is like blowing a dude,
checking the guy off in the bar at the comedy store.
He's like,
what are you doing a fucking whore.
I'll stabber she dealt with my guys but at least look,
that's like less of a secret I guess.
Is that less was it?
Yeah,
it's less of a secret than being gay.
They're like when you have a situation like a Ted Haggard,
that guy,
oh,
the priest who turns out he was hired.
He was all this pro family anti gay mega church.
I mean working really hard against gay rights.
Meanwhile having gay sex prostitutes doing math,
when that kind of shit gets outed,
I'm all for it.
I'm like,
but that is a,
that is perversion.
They call gay people perverts.
I'm like,
no.
What we do is we want to have kids,
we want to have rights,
we want to drive an SUV.
We want to like,
you know,
it's like you get to the SUV.
No,
I mean like having a kid.
That's the kid,
that's the kid car.
It's like the line,
you know queers and trucks,
no fucking way.
But when you take it to that extreme where it's like bathroom,
meth use and then you're going to preach God's word.
What that,
I mean it's like,
it's like the,
what's her name?
The Bachmans those.
Oh no,
that guy's Marcus.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's just a cute little,
very Baird.
First of all,
he's very heterosexual.
Maybe the most heterosexual man ever.
Sure.
Yeah.
No Way.
That guy's good.
I don't get it at all.
There's no way him how's barks?
No wet,
no Alice Parks by the lot.
I think you're straight.
If you tell me your straight,
I'll say you're straight.
How's parks?
I love you.
I mean,
hey,
if he's straight and easy,
settle down.
I didn't say it was not,
I don't know him personally.
He's totally straight,
but as soon as a great ass,
but he's not an asshole,
you know this Ted Haggard guy or any in any of these guys that do it.
That's gotta be a really like self loathing place to be like a gay person and to
be like angry and twisted about it and lash out like that one.
What does it Larry Craig,
who's,
that was his name,
the congressman was a senator or congressman that got busted doing the thing
underneath the uh Oh yeah,
the tapping the toes battle.
That's like that old trick.
The old speakeasy days.
Hey boy,
you gotta shoot.
I can tap before the Internet.
We had a thing we used to do.
It's called playing footsie.
I mean that's,
but I mean that's a hole in the shitter.
A generation.
I don't know if that's a general like bath houses,
that kind of thing.
That's like,
Ooh,
well that's still going on,
isn't it?
Don't you guys get to get all according to bath house weekly,
but fuck each other with masks on.
Oh,
it has to be fun to pick up guys.
Like if you want to get laid,
it's probably so much easier.
You know what I mean?
To just like,
Hey,
I might go to the bus stop and do my little gay hand wave thing.
Do I find somebody,
hey,
you leave our gay hand wave alone,
right?
Eating while you're talking about what you're doing in pig is finish your food
first.
I can't hang on to that question.
Three hour fucking punk.
You gotta eat with a mouthful of food
you muster.
You,
you're like,
I really easy to get laid
when you suck the cops,
you slobbering.
Dot.
You're like a dry cough.
Oh God.
Yeah.
It must be way easier to get laid.
I mean,
it's the same.
It's,
I think it's easy to get laid.
You guys have Tinder for God's sakes.
I've seen so many of you guys.
Just 10.
We have Tinder.
Tinder website is what you're saying?
Straight grinder.
So Tinder,
Tinder.
You could just hook up.
You just say who wants to fuck?
Well,
I think so.
Uh,
who wants aids and La Jolla.
This weekend there was a,
I was with one of my buddies and he was,
he was showing me,
cause I'd never really seen Tinder,
so he was showing it.
It looks so complicated.
It's like,
no,
but it's like you've got to like swipe this way and then you got to do this and
then you can scroll more.
I'm like with ours,
it's just like,
all right,
come on.
So with yours,
with Grindr,
say if you're a in a town or do you want a hundred right now,
shall we?
Let's,
no,
Brian,
put that down if you're in Ohio.
Okay.
And you want to,
uh,
get your freak on.
Yeah.
So you're,
you're doing a gig in Columbus,
pull up your app and say,
do you,
do you have a picture of yourself on it?
Yeah.
Look,
I'll show you ever had a fan.
Yeah,
that's what I have to kind of,
I think I have to kind of like get,
I have to wean myself.
Not that I'm like an avid grinder user,
but yeah.
What's avid?
More than twice a day.
No,
no,
no.
I,
I rarely,
rarely meet up with once a week,
every night.
Don't you know how often do you use the grinder?
Let's,
let's not throw him under the bus though.
Ruined in the guy's falling for this.
This one is,
this is my,
um,
this is B.
He goes,
uh,
hey there,
what's going on?
And I go,
not a whole lot.
You,
how's your Monday?
Maybe beat us and want you reading out his shit.
No,
no,
no.
It's,
I'm not saying no complaints.
Worked early.
Had the afternoon to myself just making dinner now.
So I'm very sexy and he goes,
ah,
I'm be nice to meet you.
What did you make?
And I'm like,
I made a blackened chicken pesto pasta dough.
I think grocer,
you're the sex coming up.
I was trying to pick up girls is guys try and pick up God's,
you're about to make me fucking grow up just with the mundane.
This of your fucking interaction.
I was hoping it was way more fun.
No,
I got to know who wants this.
Dick is a picture of some Dick.
What I'm saying?
Got It.
I'm on the corner.
No,
no,
no.
The guy drives by with his pants off.
That's how you think it would be.
That's how we talked.
I talked to girls.
No,
see I'm a lesbian.
That's what I wanted to say.
I'm just a big old lesbian.
Yeah,
you're about making dinner and shit.
You got Pesto.
I don't care.
I mean Irish garlics which is seen now.
You know,
it's like it's,
I don't know.
Maybe it's just such a scene.
It's such a scene now about the whole like just hooking up and you know,
maybe I want a little more.
We all know this.
We don't know we're on the war when the outside,
we only talk to you guys like very briefly about your sex life.
Then we run away.
I'm the Unicorn in the room.
Went away,
we clean our hands.
Just run your,
run your body through a car wash.
He keeps it pure.
L and I spray it in my mouth.
Just the case of me.
Hey,
can we do the same with you guys?
So don't worry about it.
It'll flow to here and then on my tongue.
And I might catch the gay.
I'm actually leaving here and taking a nice hot shower.
You should get a scrub.
We go to a car wash.
Just a nicest steel wool pad.
That's what I'm just going to [inaudible] I love,
I love straight people lovers.
Have you ever sneezed and poop came out?
Uh,
you dumb.
Fuck he told you he's a top.
Yeah.
Oh No,
I'm your mouth.
Oh God.
Why did you have to get gross?
Because he's a child.
I know and yes,
I have no,
I'm not what you're about to say for an extra five seconds.
Just thinking about it for an extra five seconds.
I get it.
Yeah.
What did you just think sex is just sex is just,
I think it's gross.
Either way.
You know,
fluids and sex is gross.
Poop come
well,
but you do it though still.
Yeah.
We were handled to do what you gotta do
when you don't need it,
when you need it.
Exactly what the doctor ordered.
Yeah,
that's true.
Did you like push you when you had it?
Um,
no.
Sorry.
It felt,
it feels bad to,
you know,
it didn't feel bad.
It wasn't like I'm shoving my Dick in between a sandpaper Arby's sandwich,
but like it was,
it was so gross.
Um,
no,
it was nice,
but it was just like I did it.
It was,
we just weren't attracted to girls.
Yeah.
Or you love.
It was one of those things like,
oh,
I'm just going to be friends with them.
So we did have sex with them.
So you did get aroused by girls.
It's just not as satisfying.
Right,
right.
And you feel more drawn to men.
And did you,
when you went,
when you went by,
you said you went by for a while.
Yeah.
But what do you think that was?
Was that like you trying to figure out like who you were?
Try to,
let's try it.
A lot of people do that.
This is an eight.
Oh,
this one's a,
this one's a five.
Yeah.
Maybe she just doesn't like me if I had another one.
So,
yeah,
exactly.
There was,
there was a period,
I mean there was a,
there was a time when it was,
I want to say it was like my mind,
I was like 23 I guess.
And um,
uh,
there was this girl and um,
can we get even saying this story?
She like,
we had this thing,
like it was this kind of like a fair,
if you will,
like she was engaged and yeah.
And so like it was hot and heavy.
It was fun.
But it was a girl.
It was,
yeah,
we had a good time and it was one of those things where,
you know,
she would tell me,
she's like,
you know,
you're not gay this you can,
you're doing this too well then you're,
you're,
you're playing with my heart.
And so it was kind of like dangerous at the same time.
And then her fiance found out,
oh Jesus,
her fiance actually found out when I was going down on her and her bedroom,
he walked in.
No,
he was knocking on the door outside and the lights were on.
We were like,
Oh shit.
And he was like,
Hey,
I'm here.
I'm here,
open the door with the door and immediately what do I do?
Cause there's,
I'm like,
what do I do?
What do I,
I jump in the shower like an asshole.
No,
because that's not suspicious.
Oh,
I just came over to shower her fiance's house.
You turn the shower on the shower on and he's like,
what are you doing?
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
I'll see you later.
If it was great.
Uh,
thanks for the study break and the shower,
what I got,
I had to get pussy off my face.
Right?
Yeah,
I really did.
That's the thing with a steel wall pad,
you know,
and um,
God so and so,
and then,
and then she moved away and then,
um,
I got this phone call.
Oh God,
it was so crazy.
Um,
I got this phone call from him to the fiance.
What'd you jerking off over the phone?
No,
he was mad.
He was like,
oh dude.
so what the fuck is my hearing about this and this and this.
And she's in the background and she's just like,
he's lying.
He's lying.
He's a,
he's a fucking faggot.
Don't listen to them about a year.
Oh yeah.
She threw you down.
Threw me down under the bus and that was the time and this was somebody that I
was like,
I,
we had like,
I thought we had something and when she said that I was like later,
like I couldn't like that was it.
So you,
how we'll,
do you have the time?
I was 22 or 23 and you'd already come out.
You'd come out when you were,
when you were there,
you told her that you were gay.
Yeah.
Like everyone,
like knew,
like it was just one of those.
But then you get those girls who were like,
I'm going to turn you.
And you're like,
oh,
I get it all the time.
You get it all the time trying to turn you straight.
Yeah.
Wow.
But this one,
it works for a little bit,
sort of.
I get asked it a lot.
I was,
I don't know if it was you,
it was probably,
oh,
the other night at the store.
Maybe like a week or two ago.
You're like,
would you ever like if a hot girl came up to you,
I'm like,
hmm,
that's a good question.
Imagine having sex and then just having a guy sit there with the balls on your
forehead.
You could probably love it.
You have your fantasy Brian.
And they'll have by meaning he would only see guy and balls and he would feel
pussy.
What are you talking about?
Balls.
What do you mean?
Like if a woman is on top of him fucking him and then a guy just like,
that's a threeway.
Yeah.
But you're only seeing the dick and balls that probably be the most ideal thing
to shut up.
Oh my God.
Just five minutes.
Think about what we're going to say for fun.
Yeah.
So,
um,
I dunno,
I would,
I would think,
I dunno.
I Dunno if I could or not.
I don't,
but there's no,
there's no social stigma attached to that.
If you chose to have sex with a woman,
it's like,
it's no big deal.
Whereas if a guy is a straight guy and then he just chooses to have sex with a
guy like that's in this culture,
that's fucking crazy.
That's really unusual.
But in some cultures
it's like,
I don't think,
I don't think a straight guy.
I don't,
well,
I don't think a guy could be bisexual,
but a girl could be bisexual,
but isn't that
well,
is it m?
I think definitely guys can be bisexual.
I don't think so.
You don't think so?
I've said that there's two types of dudes who do gay things.
There's gay dudes and there's really gullible,
straight dudes who get talked in the blowing crafty gay dudes.
I think that's what it is.
There's a lot,
especially in
for an industry,
there's a lot of like,
you know,
well,
we were all straight.
Yeah.
But gay for pay is a different thing.
Like gears,
um,
a lot of,
uh,
gay people will find straight guys that are really broke.
Like there's this,
uh,
this guy who's friends with my wife,
who's a gay guy.
Who's this?
Mack,
Daddy's got a lot of cash.
[inaudible] gets a lot boys,
you know I,
it is,
and he gets dudes that are straight and he had this Russian dude,
is it a website?
He runs,
she's got a car.
I got put the guy up and apartment like he was going broke because he was
spending all of his money to take care of is this a straight guy?
And this straight guy would suck his dick.
Yeah,
you'd get together with this.
The guy was like heavy Russian accent,
kind of tough luck in and like,
uh,
what's his name from,
nevermind.
He was like a gay Jason stayed them looking kind of a but with a Russian accent
and apparently this guy was just a,
no one's looking okay.
Oh,
just cheese everywhere.
Made sure that he took care of this guy,
give us kind of apartment,
gave him money,
give him the guy wanted too much.
At a certain point in time,
he actually,
uh,
lost a big chunk of his money,
try to keep this guy.
But this guy was like the latest in a series of straight guys that he had a
manipulated into.
There's a lot of personal position.
That's a thing,
isn't it?
That's the thing.
Yeah.
It's like finding straight guys.
I had a buddy of mine who was in,
um,
uh,
a wardrobe guy and he was gay.
He would always tell us about,
uh,
all the different quote unquote trait guys that let him suck their Dick.
Jesus.
He would get a kick out of it and they're really funny.
I get,
I get a lot of them too,
so,
but they're not straight guys then.
They just know they are,
they are.
Well,
how are these,
no.
Okay.
You were going to say they're confused.
They're just confused.
Do you think that you're,
it's extra likely to happen to you if you kill on stage?
Ah,
yeah.
It's happened before and more likely what it has happened,
but I mean more likely because you're,
you're on stage and you can feel and you become attractive.
Yeah.
There's that like,
yeah.
They're like,
oh,
he's hot and broken.
And so the straight guys find that attractive.
I had,
I'm actually ahead a guests.
They do.
Those guys are not straight Justin Martin Gayle,
there is no Santa Claus.
The Easter bunny is not real.
And that was a gay dudes now.
But they're like,
oh this my girlfriend.
It's like,
oh,
how the tables have turned.
Well how many dudes who put on this sort of like straight act just for society,
for jobs,
for career,
for whatever.
Fill in the blank.
How like a percentage.
It's a lot,
right?
I mean who knows?
Percentage wise that would be speculative,
but it's one of them.
And yeah,
I want to say like for instance,
I was in San Diego this past weekend and it was like,
I,
I um,
I was like,
where all the,
where are the black people?
Where are the white people who,
it's like,
where's the Mexicans?
Ooh,
where's the gay people?
I was like,
really guys?
Really?
No Gay people in San Diego?
Is that what it was just one of those like too scared?
Yeah.
Oh,
they didn't want to you I want to say anything.
And then like,
and then ambulance consultant afterwards.
Yeah,
it's very,
very conservative.
Whatever.
Um,
but then after the show had like,
like a couple of guys were like,
Hey,
uh,
yeah,
so I'm in the,
you were talking about the military early real.
I'm in the,
I'm in the military.
What are you doing later?
You want to go grab a drink or something?
I was like,
quit trying to fuck sir.
Whoa.
That's what they do to try to get you and have a drink afterwards.
Oh yeah.
Maybe some dude's spend a lot of time on a big navy ship,
which is very terrifying cause I'm like,
I just feel like I would,
I would be like a little piece of veal.
Just throw them and maybe have thrown to the wolves heal you after it's over.
So he keeps God damn secret.
Exactly.
My military career just to Martindale.
Never know.
I'm like,
that's,
I refuse.
That's not like this.
No,
I'm like this,
I want to go on a big mega volcano.
I think that,
uh,
there's obviously a tremendous amount of discrimination,
racism,
homophobia.
There's still,
it's still a tremendous amount of it,
but I think it's getting better.
I really do to culturally,
I think we're at a really good time.
Yeah.
I think those are seeing change.
It's,
it's good.
Cause I mean,
God,
for a while there was just so boring.
Why wouldn't you want to make the world a little more colorful?
And people are scared?
It's sad too.
And I've been,
I've been scared.
I go to,
I go to the Midwest and I'm terrified.
You know,
there's like parts of the country that I'm just like,
oh my God.
Like,
well,
even like I remember,
I know when I got,
well I went back to,
to Texas not too long ago.
Um,
but I mean I dressed,
I mean I feel like I dress okay.
I don't can open up.
Sometimes my shirts may be a little snug sometimes or you know,
my genes may be a little tight.
You know how the fashion style is out here.
And I'll wear that out in a small town and I just see the,
the looks just like what?
Lean even more in flannel.
Yeah.
There's a Sasquatch over there.
I ain't got no camera.
Yeah.
Oh,
his hair.
His hair's too pretty there.
He's all clean sheet here.
I'm like,
you gave,
you touch it.
It's a lot of crazy shit,
but gay gang.
She didn't know you were gay the first year.
I knew you.
I like my Gaydar never went off or I never really had a lot of shit to the shop
shop song.
Maybe it was just lost in your eyes.
Yup.
Hypnotic.
We're just lost in La.
You'll,
you were coming from Ohio Mac time machines.
They don't come up this far of Santa Monica Boulevard.
I kidnap Brian from the 1950s and brought them into the future.
He did.
Mother fucker was in a storm cellar and gateway computers.
He got robbed by a black wizard the following week after I did.
That's right.
We talked about that right by my house at the time.
He was walking back from the,
I know several people.
We were all together at gunpoint in Hollywood.
It's not pleasant.
It's not pleasant at all.
It is one of the,
and it's one of those,
God.
It was so,
did you have post traumatic?
I did,
yeah.
I still have a little of it.
I do too.
I did too.
I think it's,
it's,
it's not as bad as it was,
but it's one of those things where like if somebody is behind me or if like
somebody pops out,
like I'll,
I mean I like jerk and like,
or come down to the blue like really bad.
Like I'll be parking at night and I'd be like,
oh my God,
I don't want get in my car right now.
Like out of nowhere,
I'm just,
there was a part,
there was a time where I did not leave my house.
Like I canceled spots,
like I couldn't do from violent crimes.
Posttraumatic stress is big.
Well,
and it wasn't necessarily,
it wasn't violent at all.
It was just a like,
listen,
give me your phone.
Yeah,
it's the threat of violence.
But I'm saying it wasn't physical and that's the thing that was scary because
like he made me like walk like it was,
I was in such that he robbed me and then started walking down the street that I
needed to walk down.
So I'm following him and he turns around and he's like,
what are you doing?
And I'm like,
I'm going home.
Like I live right down the street.
He's like,
you ain't going to live down the street if you,
if you keep following me.
And I was like,
Oh God.
And so I,
I honestly,
I did the,
the Justin just the
all the eyes roll the eyes,
like God dammit,
it took me so long to get here.
And then I,
um,
some walking around the block and as I'm walking around the block,
he had
gone down the alleyway and got into this white van and the white van drove off.
And that's the thing that scared me the most was just the fact that I was
probably being watched.
Like it was,
he was the guy,
there's like three other guys probably out here.
Like what?
Like if I fought or if I tried to make an attempt to not give him my stuff.
Like they,
that's the scary thing to me that they would have probably.
Yeah.
And um,
same thing happened to me.
There was another guy in a van across the street.
Do you usually use other people?
They'll spot,
you know,
unless they're,
I mean there's obviously people that do it single and Desperado,
but you know,
if you're gonna rob a bunch of people getting a car and drive somewhere,
you look out and no one's coming.
Get this guy.
They got him though.
They,
I think they got him.
I had to go,
I had to file a police report and all that.
And because you have to go look at a lineup.
Really.
Did you share it with him?
No,
but I,
I honestly told them that I was like,
I can't,
I was like,
it was three o'clock in the morning.
It was so dark and I don't want to be that guy who likes that guy.
And it wasn't him.
I was like,
honestly,
I can't remember.
And it was,
it was such a long time after it had happened too,
so it wasn't like they got him,
Oh God.
I want to say it was like six or seven months after us because apparently it was
a,
it was a string of them in Hollywood.
Like it was happening a lot.
There was the guy who was like throwing the bombs in people's garages.
Remember that guy?
It was like right around that time there was like this crazy crime ring because
all the people from La and Hollywood are like slowly coming into to West
Hollywood and people are like,
oh,
what's Hollywood so safe and it's clean and nice.
I'm like,
no,
there's,
if you drive down Santa Monica Boulevard now,
it's like there's,
there's crazy people.
Like it's just,
it's out of control.
Everyone's losing their minds.
Do you think people are targeting people because it's so safe for the people
think it's so safe?
Yeah,
I think it's,
you know,
I mean people are stealing people's dogs.
Like that's just messed up.
Yes.
In West Hollywood,
you leave your dog in the car.
Like someone will come in and take your dog,
looks like I'm just going to roll the window down and have the dog,
you know,
get some air while I'm running into cvs or something.
Someone just comes in and checks the dog walks away.
So I was like,
there's so many shitty people out there in this world.
Yeah.
There's a lot of great people out there in this one.
But God damn to some fucking shit heads,
someone stealing someone's dog is so great.
I'm like,
well,
who does that?
That's a real piece of shit.
Yeah.
I have to be a real piece of shit to do that.
Good.
I can do with that as holes
everywhere you look.
I'm hoping that that's the,
the,
the next thing that changes about human beings.
We slowly but surely start to weed out the assholes in our culture among the
hoping that that's going to be the next evolution of society.
I'm hoping,
and your in your,
in your head,
that's the,
it's gotta be some of the thing that's gonna save us.
We have to realize that these ideas that we have like fighting over various
ideologies,
politics,
uh,
the way,
you know,
conservative versus liberal,
white versus black,
all that stuff is so fucking stupid.
I think that one day we're going to realize that our only problem in this life
as people who are assholes,
it's our only problem.
Whether it's war or theft or crime or cyber crime or corruption.
It's all the same problem.
It's people that are assholes,
whether it's rape or murder or whatever.
It is,
assholes.
It's just shitty human being.
I just slowly developed humans.
That's exactly,
I think that's exactly what it is.
Poorly developed Cubans.
It's a,
it's a mutation if you will.
Well,
we need really strict,
not strict,
but we need strong philosophies like the tall whites.
Do you know what the tall whites are?
No,
the tall whites are apparently a group of,
um,
aliens
that are in area 50s area 51 now.
And they're walking amongst us and they are advanced.
And it's like a thing that,
do you see the Russian guys a thing?
It's like a thing.
The tall whites that check out the video of the Russian guy.
No,
no,
no.
Oh,
Canadian.
There's a Canadian guy.
He's in Congress and he's like,
we all know about these aliens.
The guy's an idiot.
I've seen,
I don't know.
I saw people walking out of the ocean.
I saw,
well you didn't see anybody walking out the secondary shit.
Scuba diver.
No,
it was late.
The man with three piece suit.
Puma.
So who's thinking about killing?
I'm sorry guys.
This is a hate crime now,
right?
Calm down.
You saw an asshole.
Those thinking about killing himself.
Get home to his family and he walked out of the water and you're like,
oh mg and you ran away fucking tweeting it.
Did I say Omg,
Joe,
you do.
I look like I say,
Omg out loud is sparkles.
Came off your hill.
He ran uphill.
Okay,
that part's true.
All right.
That was true
with a nice little rainbow stream behind me.
He panicked and farting glitter before you ran into your house.
Hey,
don't be jealous that I parked glitter.
All right.
It's a magical thing.
What are these aliens you believe in?
They're called the tall whites.
They're not.
Listen,
all these people that tell you they're,
see aliens are all idiots.
That's the universal,
that's the one thing that's universal about these people.
They're almost all idiots.
I talked to the guy was a former senator on my TV show on the Scifi show.
It was telling me all about area 51 all the evidence and area 51 he's a fucking
former senator and I talked to him for 10 minutes and I just,
I knew exactly what was going on.
I'm like,
you,
you're just a silly man.
You're a silly man that happened to be a former senator.
You're a guy who a believer and you believe in and things with
zero evidence.
I mean,
there's almost no evidence except these weird photographs.
Oh,
here it is.
Yeah.
Listen to play this.
I will end with this because we've got to get out.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Let's end with this.
You're welcome guys.
Yeah.
Powerful.
Justin Martindale.
It doesn't exist.
Well they,
they,
they probably took it down.
Just look up Canadian prime minister,
whatever the fuck is the Canadian prime minister saying that aliens.
What was his official title?
Wasn't prime minister,
right?
I think it was a minister of defense or something like that.
Canadian.
We've got to find it.
Go back to the advice thing.
What is his name?
Hold on.
Uh,
what does the Guy Do?
Oh my God.
Brian.
This computer is like really shitty Canadian Prime Minister Aliens.
Is it the computer shitting?
Okay.
Uh,
Canadians,
former defense minister.
Yeah,
that's it.
Former defense minister.
Okay,
so just Google that Canadian former defense minister.
I'll bring in a,
I have my other laptop.
I'll bring that in from now on.
Yeah.
This one
catch up.
One of the species is called the tall white.
See?
Oh my God,
it's so real.
It's printed
there alive ets on earth at this present time.
O M g cabal formed by the Council of Foreign Relations,
the bill,
the burgers and the trilateral commission,
the international banking cards.
Right.
The oil cartel and the select members of the military are planning to create one
world government.
They are the ones suppressing the information about the aliens to the public
bitch.
He looked like he didn't believe in aliens.
It doesn't he,
he's a dumb ass
by reasoning and by,
this is an hour and 20 minutes long.
So this isn't the one though,
but this is probably a different one.
I think it's a different guy.
Charles Hall.
Yeah.
I don't want to fucking silly.
Fuck.
So I don't know.
That's the thing that I got out of these,
um,
these interviews with all these people.
It's not that,
it's not possible that there's aliens.
What the problem is is these mother fuckers want to believe,
but that's not the guy.
Brian,
just Google Canada's former defense minister.
You have fun or aliens?
Um,
yeah,
he,
I've seen the video.
He was on our t.
He might have actually been talking to a,
hmm.
Excuse me.
Who is you talking to?
Was he talking to Abby Martin?
He was talking to like a group of people who's like in a is my girl Abby Martin.
It is,
let's go to,
no,
that's not him.
Brian.
He's a
bald old guy.
No,
it's not Abby.
Martin says this cat.
It's this other girl.
This is the guy.
Look for this one.
See this guy?
Yeah,
this is the,
that's done.
But that's not the video that you want.
The one with him on our team.
See,
look,
it's on the Daily Mail.
This is what you want.
This silly old who's crazy.
Oh,
that's the thing,
man.
But I'm in the room where the alien,
here's where the,
this note doesn't matter just because someone says something rationally.
Shut up.
No,
it's just he's a former defense minister and he's talking to a woman who's a
newspaper,
a news caster.
She's,
she's,
you know,
I mean,
whatever kind of journalism degree she has,
it doesn't mean that she's going to call bullshit on this fucking goofy old
crazy dude.
Look,
there may very well be visitors from out of space.
It's very possible,
but it's also possible that a lot of these people are just nuts and that they
want to,
that's,
that's home boy.
They want to have like Ufos be real
well activity on the last few decades since
none of the atomic bomb and yeah.
What's up with our sound?
I think it's the laptop hard drive.
Let's get rid of that bitch today.
Yeah,
because the whole cosmos is a unity and it affects not just us,
but other people in the cosmos very much afraid.
No,
this guy is crazy.
I could look at him like,
first of all,
he looks like the creepy preacher guy from poltergeist,
which is,
I'm very offended by something that happens to a lot of these old cats.
They,
no one wants to fuck around anymore.
And there's,
there's no light at the end of the tunnel.
It's not going to change.
It's not like one day they're gonna become sexually attractive again.
And they look for some new meaning in life and what the new meaning in life that
takes away from all the worry and the wall that will worries and stress is if
there are aliens,
this whole life is bullshit.
So my miserable existence that I have,
my depressing,
miserable existence all of the sudden becomes trivial in comparison to the
mystery of the cosmos.
Right?
Aliens are real.
The whole world has been thrown on its head.
Money doesn't matter.
World politics don't matter.
Relationships don't matter.
The aliens are here.
Oh my God.
And change this idea.
It's almost like a religious epiphany sort of a moment for them.
It's like they're looking forward to,
uh,
it's almost like an apocalyptic scenario.
Not Apocalyptic,
but,
um,
uh,
what's the,
what's the term when God comes back?
Armageddon.
Well,
yeah,
revelation.
Revelation.
It's like,
like something that's gonna make our regular trivial,
everyday life that he's a failure at seem meaningless.
And I think that's a lot of these guys.
It's all these unfuckable white dudes that are out there finding new fos
Coachella this year.
It's a,
um,
it's a need.
It's a need for mystery.
It's a need for meaning in life.
And I think they distort reality in order to fulfill this need.
There's a great deal of attractiveness to mystery,
to solving mystery.
It's a part of our,
it's like,
I think it's almost like hijacks our natural a reward mechanisms that we have
built in.
Like we have this need to discover things because human beings have a need to
innovate so they can stay alive so that we can,
you know,
develop weapons and figured out how to make fire.
And so there's constant need to find out what are the mysteries,
who's planning things?
We need to find out who those people over there.
They're going to guess.
And these needs to solve mysteries.
They're responsible for all these goddamn television shows that are on crime.
Every fucking TV show is about solving mysteries and solving crimes and who did
it?
Where's that mystery?
The big mystery is a the ends.
That's the grand finale.
That's the fight.
Good works in the 4th of July one,
that ancient alien show that scares the shit out of me.
Plus that guy's hair.
Well,
Giorgio sucralose.
It was a very nice guy as is Philip Copans,
the late Great Phillip Copans who we had on the podcast.
We had two guys from ancient aliens on.
Great guys.
I love that shit.
I love that show too.
How am not stoned though?
I can't do it stone.
I'm just like,
Oh God,
they're right there.
That was a really fascinating subject and they're right about a lot of things,
but they also skirt around facts sometimes in order to make their case a little
bit stronger and there was an ancient aliens debunked video that someone put
online,
really explained what's wrong with a lot of things.
They say they'd make a lot of conclusions where they jump immediately to aliens.
You know,
it had to have been extra terrestrial beings,
extra terrestrial knowledge press.
Is it possible that extra terrestrials created humans to mind for copper?
You know,
like they have all these crazy theories.
They're fun.
It is fun to sit around and watch.
But as far as like scholarly work,
there's almost none that make any sense about aliens.
Some inch ancient images and there's some artwork that's pretty fascinating.
There's a lot of ancient Egyptian iconography,
you know,
they're hiring lifts some fascinating Erich von Daniken.
Yeah.
Who did chariots of the gods,
which is a great book and it really interesting documentary.
Well it even if he's wrong about chariots of the gods,
about the origins of these different things in his documentary,
even if he's wrong about them being extraterrestrial,
there are still fascinating mysteries.
They're fascinating and mysteries that most likely where a lot of really
sophisticated construction methods that we don't know about.
Now that we lost that somewhere in another,
it was lost in some raid like getting raided by the Romans or the Mongols or who
knows where the fuck the information went.
But there was a lot of like really sophisticated construction techniques
thousands and thousands of years ago.
That's much more likely than this.
All this shit was created by aliens,
but the actual images and the,
um,
the actual sites in the mysteries themselves are still fascinating and maybe
even more fascinating if it wasn't aliens.
The fact that people were so fucking smart 4,500 years ago that they made the
pyramids.
I mean,
that's incredible.
And that's a fact.
I mean they carbon date the,
the stuff inside the pyramids that it goes back to 2,500 BC.
So they're pretty goddamn shore that someone at least was living there,
2,500 BC and it was already built.
But just
the fact that it's at least 5,000 years old or 4,500 years old,
just at least at least that old,
that his god damn fascinating.
I've been there.
And when you see them like that,
you're just like,
wow.
Even the Sphinx to,
I've never been there,
but I've been to church teaching Eatsa,
I saw the Mayan Pyramids.
I want to do that.
That were mind blowing.
Yeah.
You just stop and think about it.
These fucking people living in a stone age time got these goddamn rocks and put
them basins of water.
There's like caves.
They're just filled with water.
How'd you get these rocks here?
What did you do?
How did you make this fucking giant structure a thousand years ago or whatever
system stuff.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Amazing Shit.
It's one of my favorite movies.
Apocalypto I love that movie.
But the people love to go.
That's a good fun.
It's a great movie.
You know it's a good movie too,
cause it's like right when he was being shamed and people realize like,
yeah,
he's crazy,
but God damn that mother fucker knows.
I love that movie.
That didn't get enough credit,
right?
Didn't,
I don't think it did.
I think it,
it,
it did.
It went,
yeah.
But I don't think,
I think everyone was kind of in that shame phase where like,
oh,
we're not going to support it,
but it's a great film.
Well,
the passion of the Christ.
I didn't see that one was,
I saw that that was not a good movie.
Yeah,
it was a,
it was basically a two hour movie about a dude who was magic,
who got his ass kicked.
I mean that was exactly what the movie was.
It was just two hours of them beating the shit out of the guy.
It was almost like a,
it was almost perverted in a way.
It was like people were like taking like some sort of pleasure out of this
torture film.
It was almost like a snuff film because yeah,
I know it's representative of the Lord and representative of our savior and all
that good stuff,
but the movie wasn't that.
The movie was just violence.
I remember a lot of people saying that it was like,
and I don't,
I think that's the reason why I didn't want to go see it because everyone's
like,
oh,
you're going to cry.
And I'm like,
that's what they want you to do.
They want you to,
Oh God,
look what we did.
Look what they did to him and it's like,
it was,
it was such a push and just like they threw it in your face,
just,
you know,
nonstop.
Do you know what's interesting now?
You don't hear about that movie anymore.
Not like,
it was a huge,
it was massive.
Yeah.
But it's,
it didn't last.
Yeah.
Like it's not something that people go and wash the day and talk about why the
passion of the Christ today reaffirmed my faith.
Hashtag God bless.
That doesn't happen.
Right?
Like maybe it happens.
It was like a secret.
Very off.
The secret was that,
remember the secret,
the secret is Mel Gibson's fucking crazy.
And when that secret got out,
everybody was like,
oh,
well fuck it.
I'm not going to see this fucking movie.
And then the one before that with Willem Defoe,
remember that one?
Which one was that?
There was a,
a Christ movie with Willem Defoe.
Very,
very controversial.
Yes.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Uh,
the last supper.
No,
the something,
something of Christ.
Citation of Christ in 1988,
four stars,
Ladies and gentlemen.
Willem defoe was Saks green goblin.
He was saxy.
Those cheekbones hadn't quite made him creepy yet.
It was just in,
in
an interesting,
there's a Jesus movie coming out.
There's a new one,
son of God,
son of God.
No,
they're doing,
there's a lot of Bible movies coming out.
There's Noah Noah's coming out.
Yeah.
Who's doing no,
us.
Russell Crowe.
Russell grow.
Yeah,
so crows,
the director.
It's like a good director.
I'm not so sure I MDB that there's,
there's Noah,
there's exodus.
Exodus is coming out as well,
so there's a Barman Darren or knob.
That guy's a bad motherfucker.
Why is he doing no?
Well it looks very like fight to like there.
It looks very the 300 like,
right?
Yeah.
There's like the guys coming out of the woods like go to the dark brown.
Just like,
hey.
Yeah.
This isn't your King James version.
It's if you've ever seen the ad,
I saw no Superbowl ad for it.
It's all extreme,
right?
The trail explosions.
Pull it up.
We'll,
we'll end on this.
We'll end on Noah.
Noah movie official.
Big Game.
Started with a massive volcano.
We're going to end with a super bowl ad.
Noah,
just pull up that Superbowl ad out.
No,
and this will be the last day you hear the shitty laptop.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I think replace the phrase God,
am I right?
Praise Jesus.
Praise David Koch cash.
No a play.
Praise Anthony Hopkins.
Isn't everything.
Praise Odin.
Praise owed and praise.
Odin is like a hashtag
stolen.
CanNot be stopped.
It can be survive.
Stop.
It sounds killing me.
Sorry.
It's almost like it's almost like taking,
it's like taking the Bible.
It's like we've got to save our family.
I'm like,
no,
it wasn't the world covered and from water.
And why is Liam Neeson kicking everybody's ass at 60 what's going on there?
Liam Neeson is in.
Every movie's kicking everyone's ass.
Here's the new one coming out as kick her ass kicker.
Some old Irish ass kicker.
Yeah.
Liam Neeson,
Irish ass kickers and everything.
Just kicking ass.
Yeah.
Holes kicked wolves asses.
C'Mon.
Irish ass kickoff.
Irish.
The Irish.
That makes sense.
Hmm.
Liam Neeson scene.
I think he's Irish.
Irish ass kick got us an eight or a sash kicker.
All right.
Good day.
May Justin Martindale.
How'd they find you?
Just Martindale Twitter.
Just Martin just Martindale and don't,
don't put in Justin Martin Dale cause it's some other dude who got a free tweet
the other day and he was like,
you're welcome bitch.
Oh,
a lot of dick got thrown your way because of that.
Boom.
Don't do,
do,
do.
Thank you for having me Joan.
Thanks for being on duty.
There's a lot of fun.
Absolutely.
More often.
Anytime.
Come on down.
Let's talk to them.
If people want to see you perform,
where are you doing?
You're hilarious.
Standup comedy routine.
It will be at the comedy store.
Uh,
I'm a regular at the comedy store,
the laugh factory as well,
and I'm shooting a pilot this month for the EAD network,
so check that out.
Hopefully it'll go.
Um,
it's,
I can't really say,
can't say nondisclosure.
See Ladies and gentlemen,
he's a team player.
Yeah.
Even under the influence of possibly any illegal drug.
Team player.
He's still stick to that nondisclosure pilot.
Ozer thanks dude.
Who's a lot of fun.
Anytime.
Thank you so much.
We'll do it again for sure tonight,
Brian.
Boom,
shallot,
yo.
Hey,
you fucked this episode of the Joe Rogan Xperience
was brought to you by 1-800-FLOWERS,
Du,
Du and 1-800-FLOWERS.
Uh,
use the code word j r e and get yourself a lovely bouquet of fantastic flowers.
It is a wonderful website.
It is a good thing to do.
So go and buy.
I just bought some with,
with that coupon code at the beginning of the show.
Did you really?
Yeah.
How'd you do that?
You're so slick.
He did it while he checked out with paypal.
You Damn it.
Sign your crane.
How do you work so quickly?
Amazing.
Um,
let me read the copy and cause there's anything that I need to say because it is
a Oh yeah,
there's a special one that's only for today.
For tomorrow.
By Wednesday,
February 5th,
it ends a 24 stunning multicolored roses for only 29 99 for just 10 bucks more.
You can upgrade them to red roses.
And this deal ends Wednesday,
February 5th,
the one 800 flowers.com.
Enter in the Code Word J.
R e.
We are also brought to you by Squarespace,
Squarespace,
squarespace.com.
Use the code word Joe,
just j o e and a save yourself 10% you fucks.
And audit.com.
That's o n N.
I t.
Use the codeword Rogan and save both of her knees.
Hope blue moons.
All right,
are we back on a Friday with Cameron Hanes?
Very famous elk bow hunter.
Talk about being specific,
but a very interesting and inspirational guy.
I'm looking forward to talking to him.
I really enjoy these videos online and a lot's more coming up.
I've got a lot of interesting guests.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to have some fun.
Um,
thanks for all the love always,
whether it's on Twitter or Facebook or in real life.
Uh,
thanks everybody came to New York,
uh,
Tommy skier and I had a great fucking time.
We do always a,
I'm consistently impressed by the quality of people that come to these shows.
Just awesome fucking human beings.
And,
uh,
you guys give me hope.
All right.
Not that I didn't have hope.
I'm full of hope,
bitch.
All right.
See you soon.
Big Cast.
Wow.
Okay.